Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 40, Unity. Take it away, Patrick. So I'll start off with a little bit of a rant. Pre versus post increment. So I got into a discussion with people at work and for a long time I have always just done,
节目由 Host Tornado 提供赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、独立服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 40 期，Unity。请开始，帕特里克。那我先发一点牢骚。前自增与后自增。我跟公司的人讨论过这个问题，而且很长一段时间以来，我一直都是直接用，
so the biggest example is in a for loop in the final variable change parameter, the normal one you do is an increment plus plus and so i do uh i plus plus or whatever so for i equals zero i is less than 10 i plus plus that's just always done it this way um and if i put a an increment on a line by itself i do the plus plus like it just reads more naturally to me like this variable you're taking the variable and you're incrementing it you're not incrementing something that you're going to read later so uh and then of course if you put it in line with other stuff i actually tend to try to avoid that um like in a statement because i actually find like i will do it occasionally but i find it to be a more cognitive
所以最大的例子就是在 for 循环的最后一个变量更改参数中，正常做法是使用自增加加，所以我用的是呃 i 加加或者随便什么，所以在 i 等于 0，i 小于 10，i 加加，我一直都是这么做的，嗯，如果我把自增放在单独的一行上，我就会用加加，这对我来说读起来更自然，就像这个变量，你取了变量然后把它自增，你不是在自增稍后要读取的东西，所以呃然后当然如果你把它和其它东西放在同一行，我其实倾向于避免这种情况，就像在一条语句中，因为我实际上发现，虽然我偶尔会这样做，但我发现它需要更多认知
load so i'd rather uh either have it be a post-increment so that it just happens at the end and it's like I put it on another line or do it on a separate line all by itself. And so someone pointed out to me in one of my code reviews that I was doing post-increment and that the quote-unquote standard we were using
负担，所以我宁愿呃要么让它成为一个后自增，这样它就在最后发生，就像我把它放在另一行一样，或者把它放在单独的一行里。所以有人在我的代码审查中指出我一直在用后自增，并且我们使用的所谓“标准”
was pre-increment. And I said, nah, that's not true. And so then I went through all of it. I wrote a grep command to i went through all of like i you know wrote a grep command to grep through all of our code and sure enough uh except for just a couple small other cases from other people every one of the team had been doing pre-increment except me and all the code checked in that was post-increment every single one of them except those like two other cases was me and it was like oh it was like one of those sinking moments where like i was
是前自增。我说，不，这不是真的。然后我就把所有的代码都看了一遍。我写了一个 grep 命令来——我浏览了所有——我，你知道的，写了一个 grep 命令来在我们的所有代码中搜索，果不除了其他人的几个小例外之外，团队中的每个人一直在使用的都是前自增，除了我，所有提交的代码中是后自增的，除了那另外两个例外之外，每一个都是我，当时就觉得，哦，这就像是那种让人心情沉重的时刻，就像我
hoping to be triumphant because like oh see everyone's using post increment sometimes there's no standard and then it was like yeah i'm wrong that's i don't know where it came from the worst is when like yeah like it's it's too late at that point you know like when the project starts you can try to fight for what you believe in but if if it's been going on for six months and you've been doing it one way and everyone team's been doing another way then you just have to bite the bullet man that's so i did so i i swallowed my pride and uh submitted a a change to convert all of my post increments to pre-increments but i still i still catch myself writing theincrements and then having to fix it later. Yeah, I feel the same way.
希望能取得胜利，因为“哦，看，大家都用后自增，有时根本没有标准”，然后就觉得“好吧，我错了”，我不知道这是从哪里来的。最糟糕的是，就像——嗯，到了那个时候已经太晚了，你知道的，就像当项目开始时，你可以试着为你信仰的东西抗争，但如果项目已经进行六个月了，你一直用一种方法，而团队里的每个人都在用另一种方法，那你只能硬着头皮接受了，兄弟，就是这样。所以我照做了，所以我收起自傲，提交了一份更改，把我的所有后自增都转换成了前自增，但我还是经常发现自己写出后自增，然后不得不在事后去修补它。对，我也有同感。
I mean, like compilers now are so smart that the difference is kind of negligible, if anything. Like, I don't even know if the instructions end up different at the end. You know, because like, if one really was better than the other, the compiler, I mean, you know because like if if one really was better than the other the compiler i mean you know there's no way to there's no way you that i know of actually i guess maybe if you used a comma right like if you had i plus plus comma and then like some more logic here versus the like that's
我的意思是，现在的编译器太聪明了，两者的区别微乎其微，如果真有什么区别的话。比如，我甚至不知道最后生成的指令是否会有所不同。你知道，因为如果其中一个真的比另一个好的话，编译器——我的意思是，你知道的，因为如果其中一个真的比另一个好的话，编译器——我的意思是，你知道的，据我所知根本没有办法，实际上我想也许如果你用了逗号，对吧——比如如果你有 i 加加逗号，然后像这里还有更多逻辑，跟那个相比——那是
the only way where putting the prefix versus post fix you know and this this other logic also had an eye like print eye that's the only way where you could end up with different behavior by swapping them and nobody does that right no i would not allow that in a code review yeah that's terrible so anyways i just have this bad like i guess i looked it up at one point i think they said it was like the original the c book or whatever kernegy richard richard something anyways uh kerningham oh why do i always forget the name wait does someone in your code review quoted a c book no a deceived programming book by kerninghan oh man i always always mess up the name uh anyways and in that
唯一一种把前缀和后缀放进去——你知道的，并且这个其它逻辑里面也有一个 i 比如打印 i——只有通过互换它们，你才可能得到不同的行为，而且没人会这么做，对吧？不，在代码审查中我是不会允许的。对，那太糟糕了。所以无论如何，我只是有这个坏习惯——我想我曾经查过一次，我想他们说这是——原版的 C 语言书籍或者别的什么，柯尼汉（Kernighan）——里奇（Ritchie）——随便什么——总之，是柯尼汉——哦，为什么我总是忘掉这个名字？等等，你们代码审查里有人引用了一本 C 语言的书吗？不，是一本由柯尼汉编写的 C 语言编程书，哦天哪，我总是把名字弄混——总之，在这本
one i think is where brian kerningham and dennis richie i was combining the two okay brain fart um the in this book they do the post increment like i did and so like i guess maybe it's being from the states and going to college here in the united states like the de facto way is writing it this way um but i guess people from other places don't they use the pre-increment um and so that's just what they're used to uh and then it's defensible to them i guess i don't know gotcha but everyone i've ever seen until that day had always done like and then like everyone on the team was doing pre-increment I'm just like what how am I the only one out here I've never
书中，我认为布莱恩·柯尼汉（Brian Kernighan）和丹尼斯·里奇（Dennis Ritchie）——我把这俩人混了，好吧，脑子短路了——在这本书里，他们用了我那样的后自增，所以我想也许是因为来自美国，并在美国上大学，所以事实上的默认写法就是这样的；但我猜其他地方的人不这样，他们用的是前自增，所以这只是他们习惯的做法，然后我认为这对他们来说是可以辩护的，我不知道，明白了。但直到那天之前我见过的所有人都一直用——然后团队里的每个人都在用前自增，我就想“什么？怎么只有我一个人是这样的？我以前从来没有
like been fussed at for this before you should you should you should just have a comment you should write a regex that puts a comment instead of every for loop and it just says like this the only pre-increment
因为这个被责怪过。”你应该——你应该——你应该加个评论，你应该写一个正则表达式，在每个 for 循环中替换掉一个评论，上面就写着：“唯一的前自增符号应该属于美利坚”。我不知道，我不知道，所以我只是好奇，好吧，但你也是个后自增主义者，所以我在想前自增和后自增到底是从哪里来的。好吧，我团队里有个人——所以在 for 循环里，这其实无所谓。我不认为任何人能真正从编译器的角度论证这有什么关系。所以这肯定只是一种历史遗留或某种指南。所以在我上一团队里有个人
symbol should be America I don't know I don't know so I'm just curious okay but you're also post increment so I'm trying to figure out where the previous post came from yeah so there was somebody on my team like so in a for loop, it doesn't matter. I don't think anyone can really make an argue that it matters from a compiler perspective. So there has to be just like a legacy or like a guideline. So there was someone on my last team
非常热衷于前自增。那个人来自苏里南，也就是前或后英属圭亚那，位于南美洲。所以也许这就像美式与非美式的区别。也许人们——欧洲人和南美洲人——学的是前自增，
who was really into the pre-increment. And that person was from Suriname, like former or post-British Guyana, like South America. And so maybe it is like American-verse. Like maybe people, like Europeans and South Americans, learned pre-increment
而我们不知怎么地学的是后自增。我真的不知道这是怎么发生的。我有，是的。我完全不知道。好吧，不管怎样，这是我的——这是我的牢骚，所以接下来是一个有趣的话题，我跟某个人聊过关于烹饪的事，我其实很喜欢烹饪，而且我——我做饭没有应该做的那么多，我在工作上挺忙的，不过——我确实很享受做饭的过程；还有烘焙，我最近一直在烤面包，但是有一个——不是新年决心，而是有点像
and we learned post-increment somehow. I don't really know how that happened. I have, yeah. I have no idea. All right, anyways, that's my that's my rant uh so on to an interesting topic i was talking to someone about cooking and so i actually enjoy cooking um and i uh don't do it as much as i should i'm a little pretty busy at work but um i do enjoy when i do it uh and baking i've been baking bread recently but have like a not a new
今年的一种目标——它持续不了多久，对吧？我父母以前烤面包，两天后它就像一块砖头一样，你基本上得在那天把它吃完。不，好吧，我第一天之后不会剩下那么多，不过好吧，我做得不多，它确实往往能保存两三天左右，然后我通常要么是吃腻了，要么就把它扔了。哦，好吧。不过，不，我一定做得更好，我不知道，也许我——不，我不知道。但后来我跟别人聊天，他们说：“哦，不，我不会做烹饪什么的”，我说：“嗯，你有说明书，这就像读程序一样，你只要照着食谱上的步骤做就行了”。
year's resolution but like kind a not a new year's resolution but like kind of a goal this year to it doesn't last long right my parents used to bake bread and it was like a brick two days later you pretty much have to eat it that day no well i don't end up having that much leftover after the first day but okay i don't make a lot of it and it does tend to last two or three days at least and then i typically either am tired of it or get rid of it oh okay but no it must be doing a better job i don't i don't know that maybe i no i don't know um but then i was like talking people like oh no i can't cook whatever and i'm like well you get instructions it's like reading a program and you just like follow the thing that recipe has yeah you really can't go wrong well but i find out like it's actually very rare for
真的不会出错。嗯，但我发现——实际上人们照着食谱做的情况非常罕见。我认为部分原因在于你必须经历失败。例如，我第一次学做饭时，完全是靠自己摸索，呃，你知道的，他们告诉我要把米放进去，我当时在做米饭，最简单的事情，他们告诉我要把米放进去。我当时在做米饭，最简单的事情。他们告诉我要把米放进去，把水放进去，然后煮沸或者说用文火慢炖，我不记得是多少分钟了。对。但我一直开着大火。我想，
people to follow recipes i think part of it is you have to fail like for example the first time i learned how to cook i was just completely on my own and um you know they told me to like put the rice in i just was making rice like the simplest thing they told me put the put the rice in. I just was making rice, like the simplest thing. They told me to put the rice in, put the water in and then boil it or like simmer it for, I don't remember how many minutes. Right. But I left it on hot. And I guess,
你知道的，当需要文火慢炖时，你应该把它调到小火，而说明书上并没有说“用小火慢炖”，它只说“慢炖”。所以我不知道那是什么意思，而且，
you know, when you're supposed to simmer, you're supposed to put it on low and it didn't, it didn't say simmer on low. It just said simmer. So I don't know what that meant. And, uh,
我离开了，回来的时候——甚至连平底锅本身都毁了，米饭直接把锅里的搪瓷——也就是特氟龙——给破坏了。但重点是，你知道的，要么你接受正规培训，要么你就会犯这样的错误并把东西弄坏。而且我认为你刚才所说的实际上是很多事情的隐喻——有些人就是害怕去冒险以及面对不确定性。我不知道——“害怕”这个词可能
I left, I came back and like, even like the pan itself was ruined like the rice it just kind of like destroyed the enamel like the teflon on the pan but the point is like you know you either you get formal training or you just like make mistakes like that and destroy things and i think like what you're talking about is actually a metaphor for a lot of things like there are people who are just afraid to like take kind of chances and like the ambiguity i don't i don't know if it's like afraid probably is like very
语气太重了，其实更像是“哦，这真的充满不确定性，这真的很难，我才不要尝试这个”，相比之下，另一些人会选择碰运气来填补所有不确定性，然后看会发生什么，对吧？是的，我想这有点像那些人，所以你可以犯下你所说的那种错误，或者说明书存在模棱两可的地方。但我的意思是，各种各样的人都会这样：“嗯，我以前从没做过这道菜，但是，你知道的，我觉得我能比这个人说的好。哦，他们要求用一杯牛奶。我没有牛奶。”
is too strong language but it's more just like oh this is really ambiguous this is really hard i'm not going to try this versus i'm going to like fill in all the ambiguity, you know, by chance and then see what happens, right? Yeah, and I guess it's somewhat like people who, so you can make mistakes like what you're saying or like where there's ambiguity in the instructions. But I mean all sorts of people who it's like, well, I've never made this dish before, but, you know, I feel like I can do better than what this person's saying. Like, oh, they call for like a cup of milk. I don't have any milk.
“我用一杯黄油代替就行了。那应该是一样的。”这有点太离谱了。但跟我谈过的人确实会做这种事。比如，“哦，我要替代一下。你知道的，上面写着 X 量的面粉。好吧，我唯一的面粉是杏仁粉。所以——应该没问题吧。”
I'll just use a cup of butter instead. That'll be the same. That's kind of egregious. But like people I talk to do this kind of stuff. Like, oh, I'll substitute. You know, it says like, you know, X amount of flour. Well, the only flour I have is like almond flour. So like it'll be okay.
是的。嗯，我唯一的面粉是杏仁粉。所以——应该没问题吧。是的，其中有些是不懂，但人们就是——越是不知道，我就越试图遵循一些指南，比如说明书、YouTube 视频或类似的东西。我不会假装自己比别人懂得多，但是，是的。是的，我的意思是，是的，
Yeah. well, the only flour I have is like almond flour. So like, it'll be okay. Yeah, and some of it's like not knowing, but it's just people don't like, the more I don't know, the more I try to like follow some guideposts like the instructions or a YouTube video or like something. I don't pretend like I know better, but yeah. Yeah, I mean, I think, yeah,
你必须严格照做，然后你可能还是会犯错。但随着时间的推移，比如我已经达到了这样的水平——例如，今天早上我在做炒蛋，我在搅拌鸡蛋时只是随意加了足够多的牛奶，直到它看起来刚刚好。我想，到现在我已经做过无数次炒蛋了。我真的不需要去量任何东西。但你第一次做炒蛋的时候——第一次就像我完全照着食谱做。对，没错。
you have to follow it closely and then you'll still probably make mistakes. But then over time, like I've gotten to the point now where like, for example, I think, yeah, you have to follow it closely and then you'll still probably make mistakes. But then over time, like I've gotten to the point now where, um, like for example, this morning I was making scrambled eggs and I just kind of like put in enough milk when I was mixing the eggs so that it just kind of looked right. And I was like, I've made so many scrambled eggs at this point. I don't have to really measure anything. But the first time you were going to make scrambled eggs, like, first time it's like i followed the recipe like to a t yeah exactly
我买了奶油，我以前甚至从不用奶油，这家里根本没人喝咖啡，但我买奶油是因为食谱上说要用奶油代替牛奶，你知道的。嗯，好吧，这也是我的做法。对，好吧。但显然这并不常见，然后人们就不理解为什么他们会失败，为此吃了好大苦头——特别是如果我在尝试一本崭新的食谱时，我必须把绝对每件事都做到绝对完美。有一次，有一个干料涂层（rub），这是一个汉堡食谱，里面有一种干料涂层，我几乎是逐字逐句地照着食谱做的，
i bought like cream i never even used cream no one drinks coffee in this house but like i bought cream because it said to use cream instead of milk you know yeah okay so that's the same way i do it yeah okay but apparently this is uncommon and then people like don't understand why they fail such a hard time for that like especially if i'm trying a brand new recipe and i have to do absolutely everything absolutely perfect there was one that had a rub it was it was a burger recipe and this was a rub and i was following the recipe kind of line by line um and then the thing is it didn't tell me how much of the rub to put on the meat like it didn't say it didn't have like a like how much rub i made how many pounds of meat i could season with it
然后问题是，它没有告诉我该在肉上放多少干料——它没说，它没有说明我做出来的干料可以用来调味多少磅的肉。当时我就想：“哦，不！万一调味过头了怎么办？”这就是你必须硬着头皮、希望自己做对的时候，你知道的。对，烹饪其实太好玩了，我喜欢烹饪。对，无论如何，烹饪、编程，好吧。好了，进入——进入实际的技术话题。好吧，我想我们对节目的顺序安排得不太好，所以这次又轮到我先说了，大家就先听听——目前还没什么好担心的——这是一篇关于 Stack Exchange 为什么仍然坚信独立办公室的文章。所以有很多
and i was just like oh no like what if i over season it and that's where you have to just bite the bullet and just hope you get it right you know yeah cooking is actually so freaking fun i like cooking yeah so anyways cooking programming okay all right on to on to actual technical topic uh well i guess we didn't do the ordering very well for the show so i'm up first again so you just hear a lot of no worry so far um this is an article about why at stack exchange they still believe in private offices so a lot of um press has come out around several big companies talking about open offices where uh there aren't the many many people kind of essentially sit in a large room and there may be like desk divisions in rows or pods but essentially everyone's in an
新闻报道了围绕几家大公司讨论开放式办公室的话题，在开放式办公室里，没有很多很多人，基本上所有人都坐一个大房间里，可能会有成排或成组的办公桌隔断，但本质上每个人都在一个开放的房间里，你能听到人们在大喊大叫。这以前被称为“大通铺办公室（bullpen）”。对，这就是我所知道的叫法，但现在人们更客气地称之为“开放式办公方案”，它以前被称为“大通铺办公室”。对，这就是我所知道的叫法，但现在人们更客气地称之为“开放式办公方案”，它本应该像是一项福利，是深思熟虑且极好的，那是新潮流，但越来越多的人觉得“等一下，除了节省成本之外，这对任何人都没有意义……”
open room where you can just hear people shouting this used to be called a bullpen yeah that's what i know it by but now people call it more politely open office plan and it's used to be called a bullpen yeah that's what i know it by but now people call it more politely open office plan and it's supposed to be like a perk and it's deliberate and it's great uh and that's like the new wave but increasingly people are like wait a second this doesn't make sense for anyone except for like cost savings um they try to so the the pros from the people who say open offices are good is that, uh, you get dynamic interaction between people, right? So you're all at work.
他们试图——赞成开放式办公室的人认为，其优点在于人与人之间能产生动态互动，对吧？所以你们都在工作。来上班而不是在家工作的目的就是为了和周围的人待在一起。因此，当你采用开放式办公方案时，你会听到原本可能听不到的对话，并与他们互动。这会——你知道的，从长远来看，这会带来巨大的生产力提升。但缺点是你能听到所有人说话。而且人们声音很大，或者在谈论你毫无兴趣的事情。非常难以集中注意力，因为任何人都可以随时走到你面前开始跟你说话，哪怕你正忙着重要的事情。所以这些算是缺点。
The purpose of being at work instead of just working at home is to be around other people. And so when you have an open office plan, you're hearing conversations that you might not have otherwise you interact with them. Uh, and this is, you know, leads to big productivity boosts in the long term. But the cons are you hear everyone. And people are loud or talking about stuff you're not interested. It's very hard to focus because anyone can just come up to you and start talking to you, even if you're in the middle of something important. And so these are kind of cons.
而这篇文章，即 Stack Exchange 公司，在阐述他们为什么坚信独立办公室。你可以读读这篇文章。从我的角度来看，我认为介于两者之间是最好的。有些地方的办公室只有一到两个人。在我看来，这有点孤独，可能不太好。所以我经历过最好的环境是，我所在的房间里大约有四到五个人，他们属于一个非常——就像团队是子团队中非常具体的一部分，所以这些人都是我经常一起工作的人，因此我需要与他们进行大量互动，而且我们有一扇
And this article, Stack Exchange Company, is saying why they believe in private offices. You can read this article. And from my standpoint, I think there's somewhere in between. So some places have offices with only one to two people in them. That, to me, is a little lonely and maybe not good. So the best I've had is I was in a room with like four to five people who were in a very uh like the team was a you know very specific part of a sub team and so these people i was people i worked together with a lot and so i needed to have a lot of interaction with and we had a door we
可以关上的门。所以如果我们需要开会，我们不用去别的地方，只要关上门就能开会。此外，我打扰到一个不关心我在谈论什么的人的几率非常低，因为这些都是我日复一日共事的人，所以我们彼此理解，而且我们更习惯于说“嘿，现在不行，我很忙”或者诸如此类的话。因此我发现，四到六个人在一个所谓的办公室封闭空间里——对我来说，那是我拥有的最好的工作环境之一。对，对，我也这么想。我的意思是，我曾在拥有巨大大通铺办公室的地方工作过——实际上我们就在那种大通铺环境中一起工作过，而且事实上在那种情况下行得通，因为那里非常安静，它
could close so if we needed to have like a meeting we didn't go somewhere we just closed our door and had our meeting um also like the chance of me interrupting someone who doesn't care about what i'm talking about is really low because like i become these are people i work with day in and day out so we all understand each other and we're more comfortable saying like hey like not right now like i'm busy or whatever um and so i found like that four to six people in a quote-unquote office closed space that was like for me uh some of the best work environment i've had yeah yeah i was i was thinking the same thing i mean i had i've worked in places that had the huge bullpen actually we worked together at uh you know like a bullpen environment and actually in that case it worked where we worked because it was very quiet it was just
天然就很安静，所以那是一个特例，我不认为那是常态。不，但——但是总的来说，是的，我曾在那种大通铺环境中工作过，你知道的，后面就放着一张空气曲棍球桌，旁边有人在打乒乓球，还有你知道的另一个人——总有人走来走去或者忙这忙那，非常让人分心，很难集中注意力。但随后，你知道的，在办公室环境中，可能会觉得有点孤独。我现在的状况是，我们两个人共用一个办公室，然后外面就是一排排的办公室，所以——大多数人都敞着门。所以这有点像大通铺的风格，你可以直接隔着门朝别人大喊，而且这种方式也挺管用的。
naturally very quiet so that was an anomaly i don't think that's normal no but uh um but generally yeah i've worked in bullpen environments where you know it's just there's like there's like an air hockey table behind you and there's like people playing ping pong next to you and and you know somebody else like there's always someone coming back or going to something and it's just very distracting it's like hard to focus um but then uh you know in the office environment it can feel a little lonely i mean the situation i have now there's two of us in an office and then there's just like rows of offices and so um like most people just have their doors open. So it's kind of like having the bullpen kind of style where you can just yell at somebody, like, through your doors and it kind of works.
从这篇文章来看，墙壁是用玻璃做的。这可能会带来巨大的差异。你知道的，因为这意味着你没有噪音，但你也可以很轻松地引起别人的注意。但是，是的，这非常难，没有明确的答案，它们似乎各有利弊。你最喜欢哪一种？是你最喜欢的办公室吗？对，拥有一个四到六个人的办公室。超过六个人就人太多了，那就不正常了——我的意思是，那是一个房间，对吧？就像办公室一样。
It looks like from this article that the walls are made of glass. That probably makes a tremendous difference. You know, because, I mean, that way it's like you don't have the noise, but you can just easily just get somebody's attention, too. But, yeah, this is very hard there's no clear answer they all seem to have their ups and downs which one's your favorite is it your favorite was the office yeah having an office with like four four to six people more than six just gets too many office that's a it's not a normal i mean it's a bit it's just, I mean, a room, right? Like, offices.
哦，我明白了。所以，我可以有多达六个人。我认为当你降到——如果你只有一两个人，我认为就像你说的，目前人们可能会敞着门。但如果——这很难控制，对吧？突然之间，这种文化可能会变成所有人都关着门。然后你就失去了所有这些，对吧？相比之下，如果拥有你的核心团队——与一个超过六个人的团队共事真的很难——也不是难，而是你自然而然地开始出现某种子团队的分化，对吧？所以我认为对我来说，当你有那种
Oh, I see. So, like, I can have up to six people. I think when you get under, if you just have, like, one or two, I think there is, like you're saying, for now, people might have their door open. But if the, it's very hard to control, right? Suddenly the culture could just become everyone has their door closed. And then you lose all of that right um versus having your immediate team which you it's really hard to work with a team of more than you know six people like it's not hard but like you begin to end up with naturally some sort of sub teaming happening yeah right and so i think to me that that is the thing when you have the
大型开放空间时，人们就会戴着耳机。这就好比，首先，你依然可以走过来跟我说话；其次，如果我一直戴着耳机，那我为什么不直接待在家里呢？对，完全没错。我听不到那些动态的对话。办公室的好处在于，当你真正需要专注时，你可以关上门，这就像是一个通用的标志，表明“我现在正处于心流状态中”，你知道的。而且，只要你——比如说——负责任地管理好你的门，那这就是一个巨大的优势。
big open spaces people it's like open on headphones it's like well a you can still come up and talk to me and b if i have headphones all the time why am i not just at home like yeah exactly i can't hear these dynamic conversations the thing about the office is like when you really need a focus you can close the door and that's just kind of like the universal sign for like i'm in the zone right now you know and like provided that like sort of you manage your door like you know responsibly then that's like that that's like a tremendous benefit yeah um yeah so the next article is react native this is so freaking exciting because I've been wanting something like this forever um so I'll tell you a little bit of history. So, so well, first React Native is the React.js kind of paradigm, but applied to native. And so I'll tell you what that means. So,
对。嗯，是的，下一篇文章是关于 React Native 的。这太让人兴奋了，因为我一直想要这种东西——所以我会讲一点历史。所以，首先 React Native 是 React.js 的一种范例，但它被应用到了原生开发中。所以我会解释这意味着什么。所以，
you know, we just, we were talking before the show a little bit about kind of, you know, web and just how like HTML and JavaScript and CSS, these things have come such a long way and there's just so much infrastructure around them. And the browsers themselves are so complex and so efficient that laying out, you know, laying out divs and, you know, getting good spacing and things like that, putting images in the right space, loading pages fast, etc. Right. It's just such a beautiful piece of infrastructure. And that making things for the web, especially, you know, things where you just want to display a lot of data or things where you want some kind of interactive form or something like that. It's just nothing can really beat it.
你知道的，我们刚刚——我们在节目开始前稍微聊了一下关于——你知道的，网页以及 HTML、JavaScript 和 CSS 这些技术的发展已经取得了长足的进步，周围有如此庞大的基础设施。浏览器本身又是如此复杂和高效，以至于布局——你知道的，布局 div，获得良好的间距等等，把图像放在正确的位置，快速加载页面等等。这真的是一个非常优美的基础设施组件。而且为网络开发东西，尤其是——你知道的，那些你只想展示大量数据或需要某种交互式表单之类东西的场景——真的没有什么能真正比得上它。
On top of that, if you make a website, you make it for everybody, right? I mean, with a little bit of good CSS, you can make a website and it can work on mobile and on desktop and it just kind of magically works everywhere. And with respect to desktop, it actually like looks and feels good on everyone's desktop. Mobile, not so much, right? So, you know, originally Facebook tried to do the whole HTML5 app, where they basically just took the Facebook website and, you know, just from a tech standpoint, like crushed it into an app where, you know, when you started Facebook, it looked like you're going to some native app but it's really just taking you to a web page where you know the address bar and other things
最重要的是，如果你制作一个网站，你就是为所有人制作的，对吧？我的意思是，只要有一点点好的 CSS，你就可以制作一个网站，它可以在手机和桌面上运行，并且在任何地方都能神奇地运行。至于桌面端，它在每个人的桌面上看起来和感觉确实都很好。移动端则不然，对吧？所以，你知道的，最初 Facebook 试图搞整个 HTML5 应用，他们基本上只是把 Facebook 网站拿来，你知道的，从技术的角度来看——把它塞进一个应用里，当你启动 Facebook 时，看起来就像是去访问一个原生应用，但实际上它只是把你带到一个网页，在那里你知道地址栏和其他东西
are hidden so it just it feels like it feels like an app but you're really you're on the internet um and the thing about it is on native you know and we could just argue this to death like like why is like whether this is a good idea or whether this can change if it's like fundamental or not but the reality is the web experience on native sucks right like the android browser the the chrome on ios and on android and webkit all of it is kind of terrible um and that's why facebook bailed on the you know web the web app app and uh i wouldn't say it's terrible it's terrible if you're trying to use like what we now accommodate as like an app like web app apps on those browsers are terrible let me think about that
都被隐藏了，所以它感觉——感觉像是一个应用，但你实际上是在互联网上。关于这一点，在原生应用上，你知道的——我们可以为此争论不休，比如为什么——这到底是个好主意，还是这会改变底层逻辑——但现实是，原生应用上的网页体验糟透了。比如安卓浏览器，iOS 上的 Chrome，安卓和 Webkit，所有这些都有点糟糕。这就是为什么 Facebook 放弃了网页应用的原因，呃，我不会说它糟糕透了。如果你试图使用我们现在习惯的那种“应用”——网页应用在那些浏览器上简直糟透了，让我想想，
i make that too many apps in a row so so like gmail like gmail like i don't my gmail app it is a website but it's really an app um and to use that on those browsers is not a good experience for me but like going to a blog for instance like i think the normal ones are fine i actually don't like the apps that are like forum readers. They just don't work well for me. Yeah, that's a good point. So maybe what it is, I think actually to be more specific, I think that web app apps are in the uncanny valley where like, you know, they respond pretty well and everything. But when you, you know, say flip a switch
我连着用了太多“应用”这个词。所以——比如 Gmail，比如 Gmail——我不用 Gmail 应用，它是一个网站，但它实际上是个应用。在那些浏览器上使用它对我的体验并不好。但比如去浏览一个博客，我觉得普通的网页版挺好的。我其实不喜欢那种论坛阅读器类的应用。它们对我来说就是不好用。是的，这很有道理。所以也许是这样，我想实际上更具体地说，我认为网页应用正处于恐怖谷中，你知道的，它们的响应速度挺不错的，什么都好。但当你，你知道的，比如说拨动一个开关，
and it's really just some kind of like JavaScript mock of what a native switch would look and feel like, it behaves just slightly different. And it's different enough that it makes you hate yourself. It's in that uncanny. It's almost like if you get it like a completely different experience on the web, you're much better off than trying to make it feel like a native app, you know? Anyways, you don't have to do any of that nonsense, because there's React Native now. It just came out. And so the idea is, similar to how React.js is this JavaScript library that lets you build a bunch of widgets programmatically. And as the name suggests, all the widgets are reactive.
它实际上只是一些类似原生开关外观和感觉的 JavaScript 模拟，它的行为会稍微有些不同。而这种差异大到足以让你恨自己。它就处在那样的恐怖谷中。这几乎就像如果你在网页上获得完全不同的体验，也比试图让它感觉像一个原生应用要好得多，你知道的？不管怎样，你不需要做任何那种无聊的事情，因为现在有了 React Native。它刚刚发布。所以这个想法类似于 React.js 这个 JavaScript 库，它允许你以编程方式构建一堆小部件。顾名思义，所有这些小部件都是响应式的。
So if I wanted to make, say, a chat program, all I do is I say, hey, here's a chat widget. It's backed by this array. Hey, here's a button widget. It's, you know, when you press it, this function gets called. And then whenever you press the button, the function gets called. That's pretty clear. But also whenever that array changes, it re-renders your chat window. So you don't have to say something like, you know, listen for new chat messages when you get them, you know, clear out the window and redraw it.
所以如果我想做一个，比方说，聊天程序，我所要做的就是说，嘿，这里有一个聊天小部件。它由这个数组支撑。嘿，这里有一个按钮小部件。它——你知道的，当你按下它时，这个函数就会被调用。然后每当你按下按钮，函数就会被调用。这很清楚。但每当那个数组改变时，它也会重新渲染你的聊天窗口。所以你不必说什么——你知道的，监听新的聊天消息，当你收到时，你知道的，清空窗口并重新绘制它。
Like you just say, hey, look, this window is this chat array and it's just magically done. So React Native is the same thing for native and it's cross platform. So what these guys have done is they've defined like, you know, like a button in this react javascript language and they've kept it very similar to the web there are some differences of things which just didn't translate well but some things like buttons are almost exactly the same so you define some button in react.js and then on android you get a native android button then on i you get the iOS button and if you define a widget like map for example you'll get the native
就像你说的那样，嘿，看，这个窗口就是这个聊天数组，它就这么神奇地完成了。所以 React Native 对于原生应用来说也是一样的，而且它是跨平台的。所以这些家伙所做的是，他们在这个 React JavaScript 语言中定义了一个类似于按钮的东西，并让它非常类似于网页。有一些由于无法很好地转换而存在的差异，但有些东西，比如按钮，几乎完全一样。所以在 React.js 中定义一个按钮，然后在 Android 上你就会得到一个原生的 Android 按钮，在 iOS 上你就会得到 iOS 按钮，如果你定义了一个小部件，比如地图，你会得到原生的
Apple maps on iOS and you'll get the native Google maps on Android so they try their best to do the right thing there and it's all reactive like I said so you could have a map widget and you can say okay I have this location variable and whenever this location variable changes recenter my map and it just magically works
苹果地图在 iOS 上，你会得到原生的谷歌地图在 Android 上。所以他们尽最大努力在那里做了正确的事情，而且这一切都是响应式的，正如我所说。所以你可以有一个地图小部件，你可以说，好的，我有这个位置变量，每当这个位置变量改变时，重新居中我的地图，它就能神奇地工作。
so it's pretty cool I don't think it's out yet so just read some articles on it Facebook put out some videos and be ready yeah that's right so our next article is windows 10 uh and the exciting thing everyone wants to talk about about windows 10 is the fact that microsoft is moving to a free for consumers asterisk all sorts of caveats potentially people whether that's true or not.
所以这真的很酷。我觉得它还没正式发布，所以去读一些关于它的文章吧，Facebook 发布了一些视频，做好准备吧。是的，没错，所以我们的下一篇文章是关于 Windows 10 的。每个人都想谈论的关于 Windows 10 的令人兴奋的事情是，微软正在向消费者提供免费升级——星号，带有各种前提条件，人们对这是否属实议论纷纷。
But the long story short is that it appears that Windows instead of, or Microsoft, sorry, instead of trying to gain a lot of money from selling new versions of Windows and waiting for people to upgrade, to try to make sure everyone's upgraded on to something vaguely resembling the latest version, as opposed to tons of people still running Windows XP, is to offer windows 10 free as an upgrade to people who have i think at least windows 7 if i read correctly that's right yeah so if you have windows 7 or later license you can upgrade to windows 10 for free and then
但长话短说，看起来 Windows——或者微软，抱歉——不再试图从销售新版本的 Windows 中赚取大量资金并等待人们升级，而是为了确保每个人都升级到某种与最新版本大体相似的系统，而不是还有成吨的人在使用 Windows XP，它将向拥有至少——如果我没记错的话——Windows 7 的用户免费提供 Windows 10 升级。没错，是的。所以如果你拥有 Windows 7 或更高版本的许可证，你可以免费升级到 Windows 10，然后
it looks like they're moving towards uh updating again for free so instead of having very long lasting os's it sounds like their intention is to move to kind of a more frequent cycle. Right. And then that way that they can, again, push features and keep people on something akin to what you get on Android or iOS, right? Instead of your computer just coming with an OS and just sticking with it. OSX does something similar, right? Like they update yeah what is about once a year or once every other year um it depends more much more frequent than
看起来他们正在朝着再次免费更新的方向发展。所以，与其拥有生命周期非常长的操作系统，听起来他们的意图是转向一种更加频繁的周期。对。通过这种方式，他们可以再次推送功能，让人们保持在使用类似于你在 Android 或 iOS 上获得的系统，对吧？而不是你的计算机自带一个操作系统然后一直固守着它。OS X 也做了类似的事情，对吧？比如它们更新——对，大约一年一次或每两年一次，
windows um from microsoft and so everyone's kind of assumed to be running something that is pretty new yeah it's pretty cool i mean there's a chicken and egg problem that this solves right which is um developers are sitting on windows xp or windows 7 um they're making apps using that so of course they're really interested in backwards compatibility and then you know you end up with no one having any reason to update um like you know as soon as a program like if if tomorrow steam told me hey you know to run steam you need to have windows 10 well then shoot i'm going on windows 10 i mean i have no choice and so um that's sort of i think the environment that they want to cultivate one where you know there's no reason for people who already have windows to not be on the latest
比微软的 Windows 要频繁得多，所以每个人都被认为在运行一个相当新的系统。是的，这真的很酷。我的意思是，这解决了一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，对吧？也就是说——开发者们死守着 Windows XP 或 Windows 7，他们用那些系统开发应用，所以理所当然他们对向后兼容性非常感兴趣，然后——你知道的，结果就是没有人有任何理由去更新。就像——你知道的，一旦某个程序——如果明天 Steam 告诉我说：“嘿，你知道的，要运行 Steam，你需要有 Windows 10”，那好吧，见鬼，我要去装 Windows 10 了，我的意思是别无选择。所以——这某种程度上我认为是他们想要培养的环境，一个让那些已经拥有 Windows 的人没有理由不使用最新版本的环境。
and then once you know say 90 of people running windows are running 10 then developers can start saying well why am i going to support seven if you could just go to 10 for free and everyone's done it so then you know you'll see developers dropping support for older versions of windows um and that will you know force more people to upgrade and so on and so forth so and i think it's it's you know the other strategic thing for microsoft is they want to start getting into this cloud business like they want to compete with dropbox on you know cloud sharing and things like that and so you so let's say something else comes out that's like Dropbox but different.
然后一旦——你知道的，比方说 90% 运行 Windows 的人在运行 10，那么开发者就可以开始说：“好吧，既然大家都可以免费升级到 10 并且所有人都已经升级了，为什么我还要支持 7 呢？”然后你知道的，你就会看到开发者放弃对旧版本 Windows 的支持，那将——你知道的，迫使更多人升级，以此类推。而且我认为，对微软来说，另一个战略举措是他们想开始进军云计算业务——他们想在云共享等领域与 Dropbox 竞争。所以假设出现了另一个类似于 Dropbox 但又有所不同的东西。
Like it's a service. It's like some kind of desktop app you download. But instead of synchronizing your files, it synchronizes your contacts. So it's contact box. Then if Microsoft sees, contacts okay so it's it's it's contact box then like uh you know if windows if microsoft sees oh that's a pretty cool desktop app they could bake it into windows 11 they can come up with microsoft contact box and it's part of the os and they can kind of run these people out which is something
它是一项服务。它就像某种你下载的桌面应用。但它不是同步你的文件，而是同步你的联系人。所以它是“联系人盒子”（contact box）。然后如果微软看到——联系人盒子，好吧，所以它是——它是联系人盒子，然后就像——你知道的，如果 Windows——如果微软看到，哦，那是个相当酷的桌面应用，他们可以把它内置到 Windows 11 中，他们可以推出“微软联系人盒子”，它成为操作系统的一部分，他们可以把这些人赶出市场，这在过去是他们做不到的事情。
they haven't been able to do in the past so strategically it's a really good decision um it probably should have been made like 20 years ago, but I guess we'll let it slide. So then the next article, this is pretty cool. I never knew this existed. So if you're writing JavaScript right now on the web you're writing um ecma script 5 and so the deal is you know ecma script is like the formal um definition of javascript like the formal name of that language and most people are writing 5 um now they're coming out with the JavaScript version 6. Actually, it's already out.
所以从战略上讲，这是一个非常好的决定。大概在 20 年前就应该做出的，不过我想我们就不深究了。接下来这篇文章，这非常酷。我以前从来不知道这东西存在。所以如果你现在在网页上写 JavaScript，你写的是 ECMAScript 5，具体情况是，你知道的，ECMAScript 是 JavaScript 的正式定义——该语言的正式名称，大多数人都在写 5。现在他们推出了 JavaScript 版本 6。实际上，它已经发布了。
But the problem is, again, you have this adoption problem. If I write it in 6, 90% of the people aren't going to be able to use my website. And so that's a problem. So they wrote this transpiler. So basically, you can write your code as if everyone's running the latest bleeding edge, you know, Chrome or Firefox. And for people who aren't, they can run the JavaScript 5 version of your code. And maybe it's a little slower or something like that, but functionally, it should do exactly the same thing. And it allows you to sort of make that transition and start writing JavaScript 6 now.
但问题是，再次强调，你遇到了采用率问题。如果我用 6 来编写，90% 的人将无法使用我的网站。这就是个问题。所以他们编写了这个转译器（transpiler）。基本上，你可以编写代码，就好像每个人都在运行最新、最前沿的 Chrome 或 Firefox 一样。而对于那些没有运行的人，他们可以运行你的代码的 JavaScript 5 版本。也许它会慢一点或者类似的原因，但在功能上，它应该做完全相同的事情。它允许你进行那种过渡，并从现在开始编写 JavaScript 6。
It's pretty cool. Very nice. Time for book of the show. Book, book, book, book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show, it's kind of a little different than usual, but I actually found out that there's this magazine
这真的很酷。非常棒。又到了本期推荐书目的时间。书，书，书，本期推荐书目。本期推荐书目。我本期推荐的书有点不太寻常，但我实际上发现有这样一本杂志，
called Game Developer Magazine and they stopped printing issues, than usual but i actually found out that there's this magazine called game developer magazine and uh they stopped printing issues i think like five six years ago um and you but you can actually get all of the issues for free so it's pretty cool i mean you can just flip through um literally any issue of this magazine you can just download it and flip through a pdf of it so um if you're into game development or you're uh um into sort of the history of of game development things like that this is a pretty cool uh resource to check out i think i remember reading that magazine in college i think there was like issues around the computer science building somewhere uh nice everybody wanted to be a game developer in college so yeah that's true if you ask around software engineers like almost
叫做《游戏开发者杂志》（Game Developer Magazine），他们已经停止印刷发行了。但比平时稍微不同，我实际上发现有这样一本杂志叫做《游戏开发者杂志》，而且——他们停止印刷发行了，我想大概在五六年前吧，但是你可以免费获得所有期数。所以这真的很酷，我的意思是你可以直接翻阅——字面意思，这本杂志的任何一期你都可以下载并翻阅它的 PDF 版。所以——如果你对游戏开发感兴趣，或者你——对游戏开发的 bzw 历史之类的事情感兴趣，这是一个非常酷的资源，大家可以去看看。我想我上大学时读过那本杂志。我想计算机科学大楼周围某处有几期——太棒了，大学里每个人都想成为游戏开发者。所以，是的，这是真的。如果你去问软件工程师，几乎
everybody says oh i got into it because i wanted to make games well i should have uh specified yeah in the computer science area i don't think if you walk to random pieces of campus it probably would have said that yeah right i didn't go to those places i would have just gotten beat up so yeah that's true because sports uh sports um sports injury majors just crush us uh that's a topic for another time um my book of the week is a book of the show is misborn, the final empire by Brandon Sanderson, which I've recommended. I think at least one other book of his before.
每个人都说：“哦，我入行是因为我想做游戏”。好吧，我应该——具体说明一下，是的，在计算机科学领域。如果你走到校园的其他随机地方，他们大概不会这么说。对，没错。我可没去那些地方，不然我早就挨揍了。所以，是的，是真的，因为体育——体育——体育专业的学生简直能碾压我们——这又是另一个话题了。我的周推荐书——本期推荐的书是布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson）的《迷雾之子：最终帝国》（Mistborn: The Final Empire），我之前推荐过。我想至少推荐过他另外的一本书。
And this is a book I just finished. It was really good. I really enjoyed it. Oh yeah. I guess it's considered fantasy. Okay. But it was very suspenseful. It's a little long,
这本书我刚看完。真的很棒。我真的很喜欢。哦，是的。我猜它被归类为奇幻小说。好吧。但它非常悬疑。篇幅有点长，
but not the longest way. But it, it just, for whatever reason, it was like very action packed on my edge of my seat. it it just for whatever reason it's like very action-packed on my edge of my seat and it was like really enjoying it is it part of like a series or could you just read this one so uh you could just read this one but when you get to the end you will run to read the next one and i think it's the beginning of a series i think there's three in
但也不是最长的。不过，它——不管出于什么原因，情节非常紧凑，让我一直悬着心。它——不管出于什么原因，情节非常紧凑，让我一直悬着心，而且我真的很喜欢它。它是某个系列的一部分，还是说你可以只读这一本？所以——你可以只读这一本，但当你读到结尾时，你会急着想读下一本，而且我认为这是一系列书的开端，我想一共有三本。
the series and then i think maybe a prequel or something that they wrote later um but this is the first one i read uh and i try not to read too much even like the titles of like other books in a series because i'm always afraid it's going to be like a spoiler yeah yeah right and i don't want to say too much about this book either um but it involves uh there's some stuff about like a little bit of like alchemy almost in it um which is kind of cool okay so but i very very much enjoyed this book and i just started on the second one like i went to start listening to another book uh so i listened to a lot of my books on audio during my commute and so um i went to start like you know reading listening to another book and uh i was just like no i want to go find out what happens i like started this book the second one
这个系列，然后我想可能还有他们后来写的前传之类的，嗯，不过这是我读的第一本，呃，我尽量不去读太多内容，甚至连系列中其他书的书名都不看，因为我总是担心会被剧透，对吧，对吧，而且我也不想对这本书剧透太多，呃，不过它里面包含了一些，呃，差不多有点炼金术相关的内容，这其实挺酷的，好吧，总之我非常非常喜欢这本书，我刚刚开始读第二本，就像我准备开始听另一本书一样，呃，所以我通勤时经常听有声书，所以，呃，我开始像你知道的那样去读、去听另一本书，呃，然后我就想：“不，我想知道接下来会发生什么，”我直接就读了这本书，这个系列的第二本
of this series so it was that good cool do you use the uh what is it called um the books on tape audible yeah okay yeah i want to look into that i don't uh i've never used it before but now i started taking the shuttle um just because it's uh it's just kind of more convenient but it does make the commute longer because that's the stuff so yeah i'm looking for something to do yeah um i totally do that so the library also is a good source of audiobooks oh cool even online so they have books on cd um which of course you can do. Or they have a lot of them. I think it's called Overdrive, which is like essentially Audible, but like for the library.
就是这么精彩，酷，你用的是那个，叫什么来着，有声书应用，Audible，对吧，哦，好吧，我也想去了解一下，我没怎么用过，以前从来没用过，不过现在我开始坐班车了，因为，呃，这样更方便一点，但这也确实让通勤时间变长了，因为就是这样，所以，是的，我在找点事情做，对，呃，我完全会这么做，图书馆其实也是获取有声书的好地方，哦，酷，甚至在网上也可以，他们有CD格式的书，当然你可以去借，或者他们有很多这方面的资源，我觉得它叫Overdrive，基本上就像Audible一样，不过是图书馆版本的。
Okay. And so you should check that out. I read a lot of specifically like science fiction, and so they tend not to have the books I'm really interested in. But I do browse every so often. And there are good books on there. Cool. Cool.
好吧，所以你应该去看看。我读的主要是科幻小说，所以他们往往没有我真正感兴趣的书。但我偶尔也会浏览一下。上面确实有些好书。酷。酷。
Check it out um time for all right of the show it's a tool of the show my tool of the show i can't believe that i haven't done this one already but i flipped through the archives and it's the first time but this is probably my favorite tool ever um it's MELD ever. It is MELD and it is amazing. So basically, just take whatever you know about diff tools and throw it out the window.
去看看吧，呃，又到了节目的“本期推荐”环节了，这是节目的一个环节，我的本期推荐环节，我真不敢相信我之前居然还没推荐过这个，我翻了翻过往的节目档案，这居然是第一次，不过这可能是我用过最喜欢的工具了，呃，它就是MELD，真的是史上最爱。它就是MELD，而且它简直棒极了。基本上，把你对差异对比工具（diff tools）的所有了解通通扔进窗户外面去。
Because MELD just makes it so much easier. So MELD is a diff tool. It compares two or three files and it will show you the differences either between the two or among the three files so you can you can hook meld into git so if you ever do like a git diff or a git merge meld will just automatically come up and take over it's pretty awesome.
因为MELD让事情变得简单太多了。所以MELD是一个对比工具。它能比较两个或三个文件，并向你展示两个文件之间或三个文件之间的差异，你可以把meld和git关联起来，所以如果你做git diff或git merge之类的操作，meld就会自动弹出来接管，这真的太棒了。
If you do like a git merge and there's a merge conflict, meld will pop up and the left panel will show what you have. The right panel will show what is on the remote and the middle will show what git tried to do automatically, which, you know, will be like somewhere in the middle, right? But it's pretty cool. You can also, if you are in a Git repository, you can just type meld, and it will automatically diff what you have, like your working copy against the repository, like against head.
如果你做了git merge，并且出现了合并冲突，meld就会弹出来，左边的面板显示你本地的内容，右边的面板显示远程仓库的内容，中间的面板则显示git尝试自动合并的结果，你知道的，也就是介于两者中间的部分，对吧？不过这真的很酷。另外，如果你在一个Git仓库中，你只需要输入meld，它就会自动对比你当前的内容，比如你的工作副本与仓库的差异，也就是对比HEAD。
So if you want to do, instead of doing a a git diff um you get like a graphical git diff kind of for free um it's pretty awesome um it has a couple of issues on mac um it's kind of there's some there's some problems there i'm actually i want to put together like a meld mac package the issue is right now meld uses the x quartz which is like max x11 kind of rendering interface um but it can use regular quartz it just has to be recompiled so um i'll probably put together like a package for that or something maybe try and like put it in homebrew or something like that but But even the X11 is pretty decent. And if you're on Linux or Windows, it just magically works.
所以如果你想做，不用去执行git diff，呃，你可以免费得到一个图形化的git diff，这真的很酷，呃，它在Mac上有一些小问题，呃，基本上就是有些地方不太兼容，我其实很想做一个meld的Mac打包版本，问题是现在meld使用的是Xquartz，这有点像Mac上的X11渲染接口，但它其实可以使用常规的Quartz，只需要重新编译一下就行，所以，呃，我可能会为它做一个安装包之类的，或者尝试把它放进Homebrew或者类似的东西里，但即便是在X11下，它也相当不错了。如果你用的是Linux或Windows，它就能直接神奇地运行。
Yep. This is what I use. I use MELD. Oh, you use MELD? Nice. It's good stuff. Although I think when I do git diff, it just gives me the – I have to give diff tool
没错。这就是我用的。我用的是MELD。哦，你用MELD？太棒了。这东西真不错。不过我觉得当我运行git diff时，它只会给我——我必须使用diff tool
we'll bring it up yeah you have to do actually you have to do diff tool and then you have to pass dash dash dir dash diff oh so i don't type that oh yeah so the way you know to diff tool it it assumes that whatever tool you're using can only diff one file at a time. So it keeps popping up. Yeah, it just keeps saying yes or no. So if you do dash dash dir diff, then it knows to take the entire diff and put it in mail. Oh, I'm going to try that tomorrow because I use this tool every day. Yeah, yeah.
它才会调出界面，对，你实际上得用diff tool，然后你还得加上--dir-diff参数，哦，原来我不用输入那个，哦，对，因为你知道的，diff tool默认它所使用的工具一次只能对比一个文件。所以它会一直弹出提示。对，它就会一直让你选是或否。所以如果你加上--dir-diff参数，它就知道要把整个目录的差异都放进meld里。哦，我明天就要试试这个，因为我每天都在用这个工具。对，对。
And if you configure your git in a certain way then you don't even have to do the diff tool or the deer diff i mean i'm gonna try that as well it's just it just magically works nice these are valuable tips jason and you just give them away for free for free can you believe it actually it costs money to give them away like we we pay for the bandwidth so other people can learn this for free my tool of the show is not nearly as useful but it is guaranteed to uh no it's not guaranteed to anything it will waste time this is an ios game i think they said they're coming out for android as well uh i should be more diligent about looking that up i do most of my quote unquote video gaming uh on my ipad uh in the evenings and so um this is called space marshals uh and this is
如果你以某种方式配置了git，那你甚至都不用输入diff tool或dir diff了，我的意思是，我等下也要试试这个，它就是能神奇地起作用，太棒了，这些都是很有价值的技巧，杰森，而且你居然就这么免费分享出来了，免费的，你敢信吗？实际上分享这些是需要成本的，就像我们，我们得支付带宽费用，好让其他人能免费学到这些，我推荐的这个工具其实没那么有用，但它绝对可以保证，呃，不，也不能保证什么，它绝对能帮你打发时间，这是一个iOS游戏，我想他们说也会推出Android版本吧，呃，我应该更勤快点去查一下才对，我大部分所谓的电子游戏，呃，都是在晚上的iPad上玩的，所以，呃，这个游戏叫《太空刑警》（Space Marshals），这个是
a game for the ipad uh and i think iphone too but i know definitely on the ipad that's where i play on ios and it is a tactical shooter so um a dual stick tactical shooter and rather than running around and trying to shoot lots of things um you're it's kind of almost like metal gear solid and like that you're trying to crouch and hide and then you're trying to avoid the attention of the guards and you can do things like throw rocks that make noises and then the guards will walk over to see what's happening and then you can ambush them from behind but if you shoot them with a loud gun it'll alert the other guards so then you may want to choose like a quiet gun that does less damage but it's quiet and so there's all sorts of interesting
一款针对iPad的游戏，我想iPhone上也有，但我确定iPad上一定有，我就是在iOS上玩的，它是一个战术射击游戏，呃，一个双摇杆战术射击游戏，而不是那种跑来跑去试图射杀很多东西的游戏，它有点像是《合金装备》（Metal Gear Solid），你需要蹲下并藏好，然后尽量避开守卫的注意，你可以做一些诸如扔石头制造噪音之类的事情，然后守卫就会走过去看看到底发生了什么，接着你就可以从背后伏击他们，但如果你用声音很大的枪射击他们，就会惊动其他守卫，所以你可能想选择一把声音较小、伤害较低但很安静的枪，因此这里面有各种各样有趣的
trades and mechanisms for encouraging you to replay the level and do better and you get a score and based on how good you do you get rewards and so they just announced and I'm very excited that they're coming out the first one is only I think 10 or 14 levels doesn't take terribly long and it was kind of like oh this is a little bit short but they're gonna come out with the second set of levels as a free update to the game. Oh, nice. It'll get more gameplay, which will be awesome. So is this one of these pay-to-win kind of games?
权衡机制和玩法，鼓励你反复通关并做得更好，你还会得到一个分数，根据你的表现好坏你会获得奖励，所以他们刚刚宣布了一个消息，我非常激动，他们要推出第一部分，原本只有10个或14个关卡，玩起来不算太长，当时就觉得“哦，这好像有点短，”不过他们会把第二组关卡作为游戏的免费更新内容发布出来。哦，太棒了。这样游戏内容就会变得更丰富，那就太酷了。所以这是一款那种“付费才能赢”（pay-to-win）的游戏吗？
No. I think you just buy the game, and then I don't think you can pay anything more. Oh, great. That's perfect. Yeah. I'm not a big in-app purchase person. No. I've gotten to the point now where if there's in-app purchases i'll almost never install it like i'm it has to be something where it's like content you know like buy another
不是。我觉得你只要买下这个游戏就行了，然后好像就没别的需要付费的地方了。哦，太棒了。那就完美了。对。我不怎么喜欢应用内购买（in-app purchase）。我也一样。我现在已经到了这种程度：如果里面有应用内购买，我基本上就绝对不会去安装它，除非是那种内容付费，你知道的，比如购买另一个
level or something then i'll think about it but if i go to the in-app purchases and it's like any kind of bs currency like if there's if if it's like there are rubies 500 rubies six yeah i'm like forget it i'm out uh but i really enjoyed this game this game's a lot of fun uh and it's good too because check this out that the dual stick shooter thing a lot of a lot of games i don't feel like go well on the tablets um just because like precision nature but due to the pacing of this one, I feel like it works really well. So definitely check it out. Yeah, do you think it will work on the phone?
关卡之类的，那我才会考虑，但如果我去应用内购买的界面一看，全是什么乱七八糟的代币货币，比如红宝石、500个红宝石、6个什么的，那我就会想“算了吧，告辞。”不过我很喜欢这款游戏，这游戏真的超级好玩，而且也很棒，因为你瞧，双摇杆射击这种操作，我觉得很多游戏在平板电脑上表现都不是很好，主要是因为精准度的问题，但由于这款游戏的节奏设计，我觉得它玩起来效果出奇的好。所以一定要去看看。对，你觉得它在手机上也能玩吗？
Or is it the kind of, like, even if they built it for the phone, would the user interface, like, with the dual analog sticks work? Except for your, like, finger covering up a decent-sized portion of the screen, I think it would work. Cool. Yeah, I'll have to check it out all right time for our discussion of unity unity um yeah so first to talk about unity we have to talk about game engines of which unity is one um i know so know. So a lot of people, you know, when they first try to make a game,
还是说，即使他们是为手机开发的，用户界面（比如双模拟摇杆）用起来也会有问题？除了你的手指会挡住屏幕相当大的一块区域之外，我觉得应该还是能玩的。酷。对，我得去看看，好了，该讨论Unity了，Unity，呃，所以首先要聊Unity，我们就得先聊聊游戏引擎，Unity就是其中之一，我知道，所以，很多时候，人们在第一次尝试制作游戏时，
I know I did this. You probably did this too, Patrick. You try to, you don't use a game engine. Like when I, my first game that I made, I used just like, I guess like Visual Basic or something. I think it was like C++, but it was like the GDI something or i think it was like c++ but it was like the uh gdi that's what it was called like it's where like the windows you actually like it was like a desktop application where i was like drawing circles and stuff on like an actual you know
我知道我就是这样的。你可能也这么干过，帕特里克。你尝试，你不使用游戏引擎。就像我，我制作的第一款游戏，我用的是，我猜大概是Visual Basic之类的东西。我记得好像是C++，但用的是GDI什么的，或者我记得是C++，但用的是呃GDI，就是那个，它就像是Windows的桌面应用程序，我当时就是在实际的，你知道的
desktop window yeah i was right i was doing like raw open gl calls oh so you're like moving on up already yeah so what i learned is that it just it there was constant flickering because the circles weren't being drawn um and erased at the same rate as the monitor was refreshing so you know you'd have a circle erased and before you could redraw it the monitor would refresh and so sometimes the circle was there sometimes have a circle erased and before you could redraw it, the monitor would refresh. And so sometimes the circle was there, sometimes it wasn't. And so you just end up with all these weird issues that, you know, you don't really think about. You know, when you're designing a website or something like that, you don't think about weird things like flickering and frames per second and things like that. Because the browser is kind of doing all that for you and because things aren't really moving around that fast and if they are you're using flash or
桌面窗口上画圆圈之类的东西，对，没错，我当时在写原始的OpenGL调用，哦，所以你起点已经很高了啊，对，所以我学到的是，画面会一直在闪烁，因为画圆圈的速度和显示器刷新的速度不一致，所以你知道的，圆圈刚被擦除，在你能重新画出来之前，显示器就已经刷新了，所以有时候圆圈还在，有时候圆圈刚被擦除，在你重新画出来之前，显示器就已经刷新了。所以有时候圆圈还在，有时候又不在。最后就会出现各种各样你意想不到的诡异问题，你知道的。当你设计网站或类似的东西时，你不会去考虑诸如画面闪烁、帧率（FPS）之类奇怪的事情。因为浏览器基本上已经帮你把这些都处理好了，而且页面内容也不会移动得那么快，如果真要动，你也是在使用Flash或者
something like that um but when you deal with a game engine or when dealing with a game where there's a lot of objects moving all over the place maybe there's a camera and the camera you know is moving your eyes are effectively moving which means the whole universe is going in the other direction um that's where you end up with all these weird artifacts and slowness and things like that and so game engines are these sort of low level you know drawing music playing, you know, physics, engines that can run very quickly and can give people sort of immediate feedback in a world where things are constantly changing. Yeah, I think the difference is like when you're writing, you know, a Windows application or a Mac application, you have a UI, but it's just a basically a bunch of
诸如此类的东西，呃，但当你处理游戏引擎，或者处理那种有大量物体在各处移动的游戏时，或许还有一个摄像机，而摄像机在移动，这就意味着你的眼睛实际上在移动，也就是说整个宇宙都在往反方向运动，这就是为什么最后会出现各种奇怪的画面撕裂、卡顿以及诸如此底层的问题，所以游戏引擎就是那种底层的，你知道的，负责绘图、播放音乐、物理模拟的引擎，它们能够非常快速地运行，并在一个万物时刻都在变化的动态世界中为用户提供即时的反馈。对，我觉得区别在于，当你编写一个Windows应用程序或Mac应用程序时，你确实有一个用户界面，但它基本上只是一堆
event handlers that fire when the user does something versus in a game yeah there's stuff going on all the time right like creatures are moving around the enemies are doing something like stuff is always happening right yeah that's right. So typically games are designed to run at 60 FPS. I know that like when they do backporting, so if you try and run Grand Theft Auto 4 on Xbox 360, it runs at 30 FPS. But for the most part, things run at 60 FPS. And what that means is that's 60 frames per second.
事件处理器，只有在用户做出某些操作时才会触发；而在游戏中，对吧，随时随地都有事情在发生，比如角色在到处走动，敌人们在搞事情，总是有各种事情在发生，对吧？对，没错。所以通常游戏都被设计成以60 FPS的帧率运行。我知道当他们做移植时，如果你试图在Xbox 360上运行《侠盗猎车手4》（Grand Theft Auto 4），它运行的帧率是30 FPS。但大多数情况下，游戏都是以60 FPS运行的。这意味着什么呢，这就是每秒60帧。
So you have 1 60th of a second to do everything like you know everything Patrick was talking about like all those people they have to move like take a little bit of a step forward you know all the cars they have to move a little bit forward they all have to make noise you know the camera if you're moving forward that means the whole world has to move backwards to give you the feeling of going forward and all that has to happen and get pushed to the graphics card the sound card and all those other peripherals in 16 milliseconds which is which is which is no time at all um so this would be really hard for you to do by uh you know um by scratch it would be it would be pretty it'd be pretty much impossible
所以你只有六十分之一秒的时间来完成所有事情，就像帕特里克刚才说的那些，所有角色都必须移动——比如往前迈一小步，所有汽车都必须往前开一点，它们都必须发出声音，摄像机如果你向前移动，这意味着整个世界必须向后移动，以此来给你一种向前移动的感觉，所有这一切都必须在16毫秒内完成并推送给显卡、声卡以及所有其他外设，16毫秒简直是短得不可思议，所以如果你想从头到尾全靠自己硬写，这几乎是不可能的任务
no you can't do it but what you end up doing is recreating most of what a game engine provides you end up writing it yourself right like this is what happened to me i wrote this game and i was like oh i need to handle the death sequence of like the character and i was like oh this is something later i've realized like oh game engines just have like these kinds of things thought out like there's a level start and a level end um or a game start and a game end versus me like i had to write like oh i'm in a splash screen now i'm in the game um yeah absolutely i mean i think that um you know if you actually i don't think it's even possible like if you just if you wanted to make a game and you want it to be like very interactive 3d
不，你根本做不到，但你最终会做的事，其实是把游戏引擎原本提供给你的绝大部分功能重新实现一遍，你得自己把它们全写出来，对吧？就像我当年的经历一样，我写了这个游戏，然后心想：“哦，我需要处理角色的死亡动画序列，”结果发现，哦，这其实是以后才会遇到的事情，我后来才意识到，游戏引擎早就把这些东西都考虑周全了，比如有“关卡开始”和“关卡结束”，或者“游戏开始”和“游戏结束”，而我呢，还得自己去写诸如“我现在处于闪屏界面，现在我进入游戏了”之类的逻辑，对，绝对是这样，我的意思是，我觉得，呃，如果你真的，我觉得这甚至是不可能的，如果你想制作一款游戏，并且希望它是那种高度互动的3D
things like that and run in real time but not use like open gl or direct x it's pretty much impossible because those are the ways, those are the APIs that give you access to the graphics card and OpenAL or DirectSound, that's how you get access to the sound card. Otherwise, you just, you're not able to use, you know, all of the hardware on the machine and you can't, you know, you can't run fast enough. So, yeah, so you need very special APIs, which give you a ton of, like, control,
内容，并能实时运行，但又不想使用OpenGL或DirectX，那几乎是不可能的，因为这些正是能够让你访问显卡的API，而OpenAL或DirectSound则是你访问声卡的途径。否则，你根本无法使用机器上的所有硬件，也无法让游戏运行得足够快。所以，是的，你需要非常特殊的API，它们能为你提供极高的控制权，
an incredible amount of control so that you can do things very quickly. But they also will allow you to do very bad things. If you, you know, and OpenGL is a lot better now. But actually, there was a time where i gave patrick remember i gave you a version of maim this is we were traveling for work yes i do and uh i gave patrick a version of maim that had some bad opengl code and his screen flipped in other words like like his screen rotated 90 degrees and it stayed that way i had to reboot even when he closed the program his laptop screen like he had to turn his head to read everything until he shut down so i mean that's the kind of control you get but it but it
难以置信的强大控制权，这样你才能把事情处理得非常快。但它们同时也允许你做非常糟糕的事情。如果你，你知道的，当然现在的OpenGL要好得多。但事实上，曾经有一次，我给过帕特里克一个版本的Maim，当时我们是一起出差，是的，我记得，我给过帕特里克一个版本的Maim，里面包含了一些写得不好的OpenGL代码，结果他的屏幕直接翻转了，换句话说，就像是他的屏幕旋转了90度，而且就一直保持那个状态，我甚至不得不重启电脑，即便他关闭了程序，他笔记本屏幕依然是那样，他必须歪着头才能看清屏幕上的所有东西，直到他关机重启。所以，这就是你获得的控制权，但
comes at a big price um the other thing that a game engine is really like uh known for is is which patrick alluded to earlier is the content creation pipeline. So you might have an artist or a game designer, and he's not a programmer, right? I mean, he's just somebody who knows a lot about games and sort of how to, you know, where to reward the player for exploring and how to create like nice niches how to make them buy that in in-game currency jason hates yeah how to buy like an extra 100 twiddly bits um like where to create kind of funnels where you can create a lot of action and force people to have to experience that action so there's not like large parts of the game that people aren't experiencing um so they know a lot about sort of the game design and the storytelling, but they know nothing about coding.
这需要付出巨大的代价，呃，游戏引擎另一个非常著名的地方，就像帕特里克刚才提到的那样，就是内容创作管线（content creation pipeline）。比如说你有一个美术人员或者游戏设计人员，但他不是程序员，对吧？我的意思是，他只是一个对游戏非常了解、深知如何在探索中给予玩家奖励、如何在游戏里设计好玩的小环境、如何诱导玩家去购买杰森最讨厌的游戏内货币、
And so there needs to be a way for those people to take the scripts that you write for them and inject them into the game using some kind of nice graphical environment. And there has to be a way for the artists to take pictures of backdrops, take little 3D models that they're making in some completely separate third-party program, and feed that into your game engine. Someone might make a death animation in Blender and then go to 3D Studio Max to make a dialogue animation. And somehow these things need to 3D Studio Max to make like a dialogue animation and somehow
如何诱导玩家购买额外的100个小零碎、如何在游戏里设计漏斗来制造大量动作并强迫玩家去体验这些动作，从而避免游戏中出现大片无人问津的空白区域的人。所以他们对游戏设计和讲故事非常在行，但对代码却一窍不通。因此，需要有一种方法，让这些人能够把你为他们编写的脚本，通过某种友好的图形化环境注入到游戏当中。同时，还得有一种方法，让美术人员能够导入背景图片，导入他们在完全独立的第三方程序中制作的各种小型3D模型，并把这些东西喂给你的游戏引擎。有人可能会在Blender里做一个死亡动画，然后去3D Studio Max里做一个对话动画。而这些东西无论如何都需要
these things need to flow into your game engine so you know commercial or popular you know open source game engines will have a content creation pipeline yeah even how to take a model and like get the polygon drawing that OpenGL needs to do right like this is something that you have to code by yourself when you're writing in OpenGL or find an individual library for every aspect of it. This is one of the pains for us was like, what is a tool that we can integrate well that allows us to use any 3D modeling program
能够顺畅地流转到你的游戏引擎里，所以你知道，商业的或流行的开源游戏引擎都会有一条完整的内容创作管线。对，甚至是如何导入模型，并生成OpenGL绘图所需的各种多边形，这本来是你用OpenGL编写代码时必须自己去搞定的事情，或者你得为每个环节都去寻找单独的库。对我们来说，当年的痛点之一就是：有什么工具能让我们很好地集成，从而既能使用任何3D建模程序
to create a model of a boat and put it in the game and not have to like draw every individual polygon? Yeah, exactly. Yep. And then you get into texturing and put it in the game and not have to like draw every individual polygon yeah exactly yeah and then you get into texturing and there's just there's a whole world full of of um like you know content related tools and things like that that you know that a game engine has to support um there's some other kind of more modular parts of the game engine, you know, AI, you know, pathfinding or some kind of state machine. There's physics engines, you know, like Angry Birds where you launch the bird and it goes
来创建一个船只模型并把它放进游戏里，又不用去亲手绘制每一个单独的多边形呢？对，完全正确。没错。然后你就得面对材质贴图，把它放进游戏里，而不需要去画每一个单独的多边形，对，确实如此，接着你会接触到纹理贴图，这里面包含了一个由各种内容相关工具构成的庞大世界，游戏引擎必须支持这些东西，呃，游戏引擎还有一些其他更模块化的部分，比如人工智能（AI）、寻路算法或者某种状态机。还有物理引擎，就像《愤怒的小鸟》那样，你发射小鸟，它飞过空中并坠毁，其交互反应就像是乒乓球，或者说，像是一个台球桌，一个撞球台。所以所有这些，通常一个游戏引擎都会为所有这些其他任务提供相应的模块。
kind of flying through the air and crashes and reacts kind of like a ping pong or sorry, like a pool table, like a billiards table. So all of these are kind of you know a game engine will typically have your modules for all of these other tasks um so now we've kind of described game engines let's kind of walk through sort of a history of game engines um well maybe a little less of a history more of like an overview yeah that's true history is boring like a chronological yeah there's a ton of game engines that came out in the past like i mean the id soft like id one id two id three the games like you know duke nukem and all of those
既然我们已经描述了游戏引擎，那我们不妨来梳理一下游戏引擎的发展历史，好吧，与其说是历史，不如说是一个概述，对，确实如此，历史挺无聊的，像那种按时间顺序排列的，呃，过去出现过大量的游戏引擎，我的意思是，比如id Software的id 1、id 2、id 3引擎，《毁灭公爵》（Duke Nukem）之类的游戏以及所有这些
there's engines behind all of those but um it would take us all day to cover the first game engine i ever used and this is a pretty high level uh game engine it's called like rpg maker and this is i think still like they still make versions of it to today and that's basically if there are a lot of rpg games which are really similar like japanese rpgs of a certain era think like final fantasy three four five like that that time range um yeah or what would that be like dragon quest four uh three like six i think up to like maybe six so like before kind of well at least the ones i was using before 3d they're all very similar you've got some guy on a world map and he kind of wanders around and occasionally he gets a random fight and then occasionally he like goes into some town
游戏背后都有引擎支撑，但，要把它们全讲完我们得花上一整天的时间。我用过的第一个游戏引擎，这是一个抽象程度相当高的游戏引擎，名字叫RPG Maker（RPG制作大师），我想直到今天他们依然在制作这个软件的新版本。基本上，有许多玩法非常相似的RPG游戏，比如某个特定时代的日式RPG，你可以想想《最终幻想3、4、5》那个时期的作品，
and then there's like a more detailed zelda-esque like detailed city map and he goes around and typically there aren't random fights there or there may be or whatever um and so what it does is is it created a very generic kind of game like this but then it allowed you to make the sprite for your hero and the sprite for your party and how many people would you allow in your party and when you go into the town here's a character what do they look like what script do they follow and you would type out the script and you know here's what tiles do you want to use for the city um and they had like a lot of i guess template games which you could start with and then kind of like modify and it was almost like a choose your own adventure to build an rpg make rpg and then at the end of it
对，或者像是《勇者斗恶龙4》、《3》，大概到《6》左右吧，也就是在3D化之前的那些作品，它们都非常相似。你在一个世界地图上操纵着某个角色到处闲逛，偶尔会随机触发战斗，偶尔会走进某个城镇，然后会切换到一个更详细的、类似《塞尔达传说》风格的详细城市地图，你在里面四处走动，通常那里没有随机遇敌，或者也可能有，随便啦。所以它做的事情就是，创建了一种非常通用的这类游戏，但同时允许你为你的主角制作精灵图（sprite）、为你的队伍制作精灵图，你可以允许队伍里有多少人，当你走进城镇时，这里有一个角色，他们长什么样，他们遵循什么脚本，你可以把脚本打出来，你知道的，你想在城市里使用什么样的瓦片地图（tiles），而且他们自带了很多，我猜是模板游戏，你可以从这些模板开始，然后进行修改，这几乎就像是“挑选你自己的冒险”来制作RPG，制作RPG，最后
like you could start with an example project and then at the end of it like you could start with an example project and just change the name of the characters or you know change your own uh like sort of like leveling system i feel like that's that's a big part of these games is sort of like how the character progression yeah so i i mean i'm trying to remember now correctly but at a minimum like you could specify kind of like how you wanted like this monster gives this many experience points so of course like the first thing you do because you want to be awesome is like this monster has like one health and like a million experience points right that doesn't make for like a fun game but that's what you do because it's fun um yeah and so stuff like that but then you know ultimately at the time like i wasn't really
你可以从一个示例项目开始，最后，你可以从一个示例项目开始，仅仅修改一下角色的名字，或者修改你自己的升级系统。我觉得这是这类游戏的一个大头，也就是角色的成长机制。所以，我的意思是，我尽量准确地回忆一下，至少你可以指定诸如“这个怪物提供这么多经验值”之类的规则，所以当然，你做的第一件事，因为你想让自己变得超级强大，就是把这个怪物设为只有1点生命值，但能提供100万经验值，对吧？这虽然做不出什么好玩的游戏，但你就是会这么干，因为这样很有趣，
into programming uh so this is like pretty early on and so i didn't get into the whole like scripting part of it as much but that's a big aspect as well like how do you do leveling like well here's your generic leveling system but if you want to write your own you can too um yeah right i i played this i had this one called Unlimited Adventures which is very similar to RPG Maker but it was from the Forgotten Realms people so it was all like the Dungeons and Dragons
对吧，诸如此类的事情。不过最终在当时，我对编程其实并不是那么热衷，所以这是在比较早的时候，我也没怎么深入研究脚本编写的部分，但这也是一个很大的方面，比如你如何设计升级系统？嗯，这里有通用的升级系统，但如果你想自己写一个，你也可以自己写，对吧，没错，我以前玩过这个，我当时玩过一个叫《无限冒险》（Unlimited Adventures）的软件，它和RPG Maker非常相似，但它是“被遗忘的国度”（Forgotten Realms）官方出品的，所以它完全是基于《龙与地下城》（Dungeons & Dragons）
rule base and the first thing I did I made this thing where like you walk to the town and when you enter the town there was a huge battle between these like 400 city guards versus like 120 dragons and uh and the battle took like three hours and i was like you know this is
规则打造的，我做的第一件事就是制作了一个场景：你走到一个城镇里，当你进入城镇时，会爆发一场规模宏大的战斗，大约有400名城市卫兵对抗120头巨龙，然后这场战斗持续了整整三个小时，我当时就觉得，这真是酷毙了，
totally awesome and i gave it to a friend of mine and he's like yeah i let that run overnight and i came back and it was you know like my computer had crashed so it was like i realized it was like actually really hard to make a good game like one that's true like as a game developer you get caught up in like the mechanics and things like that and then you end up like kind of self-absorbed then you give it to somebody who you know isn't like hasn't been like walking through the development process and they're like yeah this is crap yeah yeah um and so similar to the description rpg maker i guess in a way is i remember playing all the lucas arts point and click adventures um yeah and these all run on a similar that's called scum oh the name just escaped me it's like scripting for
然后我把它拿给我的一个朋友看，结果他说：“哦，我让它运行了一整夜，第二天来看的时候，我的电脑已经崩溃了。”所以我意识到，制作一款优秀的游戏其实真的很难，真正优秀的游戏，就是作为游戏开发者，你很容易陷入到机制之类的细节里无法自拔，最后变得有点自我陶醉，然后当你把它交给一个并没有经历过开发过程的人时，他们会说：“这简直是垃圾。”对，确实如此，呃，所以就像RPG Maker的描述一样，我记得我以前玩过所有卢卡斯艺术（LucasArts）的点击式冒险游戏，
script creation utility for maniac mansion i looked it up i cheated um okay and so these were if you remember like the indiana jones and the fate of atlantis i remember playing this game and it was so hard i had to like barely just got internet i would like go on the internet and look up like how do you get past this level uh grim fandango um what are those like the monkey island uh games these were all games that were written in this uh scum language and you would be able to provide like here's the verbs i want to use here's the nouns i want to use and here's the picture of the town that I want this adventure to take place and where the special areas are yeah so I've used scum VM a little bit they had a game that was free or I guess like GPL
对，这些游戏都运行在一个相似的引擎上，叫做SCUMM，这个名字我差点忘了，意思是“针对《疯狂大楼》（Maniac Mansion）的脚本创作实用程序”（Script Creation Utility for Maniac Mansion），我刚刚查了一下，我作弊了。好吧，所以如果你还记得《夺宝奇兵：亚特兰蒂斯之谜》（Indiana Jones and the Fate of Atlantis），我记得我当年玩这款游戏时觉得太难了，我当时刚装好网线没多久，就会上网去查“怎么才能过这一关”；还有《冥界狂飙》（Grim Fandango）；那些《猴岛小英雄》（Monkey Island）系列游戏，这些游戏全都是用这种SCUMM语言编写的，你可以在里面提供：这是我想用的动词，这是我想用的名词，这是我想让这场冒险发生的城镇图片，以及特殊区域都在哪里。所以我也稍微用过一点ScummVM，他们有一款游戏是免费的，或者说采用GPL
or something on scum VM called like was it like a flight of the amazon queen or something like that and there was another one called beneath the steel sky have you played these ones yes yes yeah yeah that was pretty cool it's pretty amazing um so you can write your own uh using the same same engine is it hard to make like i mean is it some weird format or is it do they have a scum vm maker i've not actually tried that one so i don't know yeah i should i'll check it out i should i should try one i guess we should make a crazy adventure game where you have to survive silicon valley i i think you should have to survive having uh two kids running around the house causing havoc that's that's like playing on impossible find the tv remote that one of your children is deliberately hiding because
协议什么的，在ScummVM上运行，叫做《亚马逊女王的飞行》（Flight of the Amazon Queen）之类的，还有另一个叫《钢铁苍穹之下》（Beneath a Steel Sky），你玩过这些吗？玩过，玩过，对，对，那个挺酷的。这真的很神奇，所以你可以用同一个引擎编写你自己的游戏，制作这种游戏难吗？这是一种很奇怪的格式吗？还是说他们有ScummVM制作器（ScummVM maker）？我其实没用过那个，所以我不知道。好吧，我应该去看看，我应该尝试做一个，我猜我们应该制作一个疯狂的冒险游戏，在里面你必须在硅谷生存下来。我觉得你应该去应付家里有两个到处乱跑、大搞破坏的小孩，那才叫开启了地狱难度，去寻找被你的某个孩子故意藏起来的电视遥控器，因为
they think it's funny use belt on no i'm just uh low level game engines uh yeah seriously these don't ever do that okay low level game engine um so so we talked about high level you know rpg maker scum vm things like that and we'll talk about unity but um a lot of these like they don't give you kind of raw access right so um you know in say they're not generic you can't use them to make any kind of game you want right the ones we've talked about so far yeah exactly yeah like if you um if you want to say like you can't make a flight simulator in rpg maker yeah exactly you know it doesn't make sense so i mean at the low level like what is every game doing um nowadays right it's doing one of two things either drawing triangles in 3d that are getting kind of crushed
他们觉得这很有趣，用皮带抽……不，我只是开玩笑，低级游戏引擎，呃，说真的，千万别这么干。好吧，低级游戏引擎，所以我们聊了高级游戏引擎，比如RPG Maker、ScummVM之类的，我们接下来会谈谈Unity，但很多这样的引擎，它们不会给你提供底层的直接访问权限，所以，呃，你知道的，它们不是通用的，你不能用它们制作任何你想制作的游戏，我们目前聊到的这些引擎是这样的，对，完全是这样，如果你想说，你没法用RPG Maker做一个飞行模拟器，对，确实如此，那根本说不通。所以我的意思是，在底层，现在每个游戏到底都在做什么？
into 2d by the gpu getting rasterized um or they're drawing sprites in 2D, so which are just kind of, you know, pictures that they're drawing in 2D, or some combination of the two, right? Same thing with audio. What are you doing? You're taking a variety of audio signals that are positioned in either 2D or 3D, and then you are muxing them together, are mixing them together into one signal and then sending that to an audio processor. So what these low-level engines do is they try to abstract as much as possible while
无非在做两件事：要么是在3D中绘制三角形，然后被GPU压扁变成2D并进行光栅化（rasterized）；要么是在2D中绘制精灵图（sprites），也就是在2D中绘制的图片，或者两者的某种结合，对吧？音频也是一样。你在做什么？你把大量定位在2D或3D空间中的音频信号收集起来，然后把它们混音组合成一个单一的信号，再发送给音频处理器。所以这些底层的引擎所做的，就是尽可能地进行抽象，同时
still giving you the freedom to do what we just described like to make any game you could ever want um so the most common one is sdl so sdl is um you know has things like you know add audio track or you know draw 2d box draw sprite move sprite things like that and then under the hood they've written what that means you know in a hundred different platforms so if you draw a box on windows or if you draw a box on linux or on the iphone or on the you know android phone or whatever there's a there's a line of code that handles that so sdl just think of it as like the same draw box function implemented like 30 different ways so that when you call it, you don't have to think about it.
依然给你足够的自由去实现我们刚才描述的功能——制作任何你能想象得到的游戏。所以最常用的就是SDL。SDL拥有诸如添加音轨、绘制2D方框、绘制精灵图、移动精灵图等功能，而在底层，他们已经在上百个不同的平台上实现了这些功能对应的代码。所以在Windows、Linux、iPhone、Android手机或任何其他平台上绘制一个方框，都有对应的代码行来处理。所以你可以把SDL简单理解为：同一个绘制方框的函数被实现了大约30次，这样当你调用它时，就完全不用去操心平台差异了。
SMFL is similar. It's a little bit more modern, but it's the same idea. There's also this combination of three libraries, ogre, ois, and openal. Ogre does graphics, ois does input, and openal does sound. When you put the three of them together you have kind of the same thing. There's hacks which is very similar and then something is becoming much more popular now is the whole HTML5 canvas thing, which is pretty cool. So, you know, in canvas, you can say like raw things like draw a circle, move a circle, things like that. And then it will sort of do the right thing.
SFML也很类似。它稍微更现代一些，但核心理念是相同的。还有由三个库组合而成的技术栈：Ogre、OIS和OpenAL。Ogre负责图形，OIS负责输入，OpenAL负责声音。当你把这三者结合在一起时，其实就得到了类似的效果。还有Hacks，也非常类似。现在越来越流行的一种技术是整个HTML5 Canvas画布方案，这相当酷。所以，在Canvas中，你可以直接调用原生的命令，比如画个圆、移动个圆之类的。然后它就会自动做出正确的处理。
So on the iPhone, the HTML5 canvas will call whatever the, you know know low level draw circle function is for the iphone so um yeah the low level ones are cool i mean it's it's pretty clear like if you use a low level as the name suggests you're going to be writing a lot more code i mean talking about like the uh content creation stuff we mentioned earlier you're going to be doing all of that from scratch and it's going to take you know months and months but you know that's the fun part yeah it's true but if you want to make something like say minecraft which is just very very different like uh you know minecraft it's it's the world is made up of like a billion of those little cubes and you can't just draw a billion cubes in 16 milliseconds.
所以在iPhone上，HTML5 Canvas会调用针对iPhone的底层画圆函数，所以，呃，底层引擎确实很酷，我的意思是，很明显，如果你使用底层引擎，正如其名，你需要编写的代码要多得多。就像我们前面提到的内容创作那些事，你必须从头到尾全部自己搞定，这需要耗费数月又数月的时间，不过，这正是乐趣所在。确实如此，但如果你想制作类似《Minecraft》（我的世界）这样的游戏，它的风格非常非常独特，你知道的，《Minecraft》的世界是由大约十亿个这样的小方块组成的，你可没办法在16毫秒内画出十亿个方块。
It just doesn't work. So you have to be really clever about which cubes I draw and stuff like that. And so whenever you need that much kind of precise control, then you have to use a low-level engine. And that's why you don't see a lot of like really fancy artwork and things like that in minecraft because they um you can't just take some model that you made in like blender with the animations and everything and just put it in minecraft and it magically worked um yeah if you're going to do everything you need a disproportionately large team
根本行不通。所以你必须非常聪明地去决定到底画哪些方块，以及诸如此类的事情。每当你需要如此精准的控制时，你就必须使用底层引擎。这也是为什么你在《Minecraft》里看不到太多非常华丽的美术画面之类的东西，因为它们，你不能随便拿一个在Blender里做好的带有动画的精美模型，直接塞进《Minecraft》里就能神奇地运行。对，如果你打算事必躬亲，你就需要一个规模大得不成比例的团队
the more you're going to do right if you're going to do everything from scratch right um you need a disproportionately large team the more you're gonna do right if you're gonna do everything from scratch right um you need more and more people and then more people to handle the the interactions between them yeah exactly so you end up with like 100 person game teams yeah can you imagine like a hundred people all working to make one is that reasonable i mean i feel like i saw something about some of the games now getting to that size yeah i totally believe it but uh that's pretty wild i mean there's i think there's the other day i was uh talking to a friend of mine who worked at ea and he said there was there's like a handful of people who work on the madden
你做的事情越多，对吧？如果你打算从头到尾自己做所有事情，对吧，你需要越来越多的人，然后还需要更多的人来处理他们之间的协作互动。对，完全是这样，所以最后你可能会有一支上百人的游戏开发团队。你能想象一百个人一起合力制作一款游戏吗？这合理吗？我的意思是，我感觉我好像听说过现在有些游戏的规模已经达到这个量级了。对，我完全相信，但这太疯狂了。我的意思是，前几天我和一个在EA工作的朋友聊天，他说仅负责《麦登橄榄球》（Madden football）草坪效果的开发人员就有好几个，他们所有的工作就是让草坪看起来尽可能逼真。仅仅为了草坪，就有一个团队的人在搞这事。所以这种事确实存在。对，正如你所说，这并不让人意外。
football and all they do is the grass like they try and make the grass look as realistic as possible. But there's like an army of people just for the grass. So it happens. Yeah, like you said, it's not surprising. Yeah. So, okay, Unity. So Unity is a high level game engine. So it's doing a lot of work for you. The basic premise behind Unity is that you have this thing called prefabs.
所以，好吧，Unity。Unity是一个高级游戏引擎。所以它为你代劳了大量的工作。Unity背后的基本前提是，你有一个东西叫做“预制件”（prefabs）。
And the idea is this, let's say you're making some Grand Theft Auto level, right? So you have a bunch of streets and at the end of every street you have a traffic light. Well, you don't want to have to create 10 billion traffic lights. And then, oh, I don't really like the way the traffic light looks, so I have to go and change all of them, and it would take forever. So you have this idea called a prefab, where you sort of design one traffic light that you know kind of looks really well and captures as much of the essence of all the traffic lights as you can capture and then you just instantiate that prefab all over the place and so then if later on if your
它的核心理念是这样的：假设你正在制作某个《侠盗猎车手》风格的关卡，对吧？所以你有很多街道，在每条街道的尽头都有一个红绿灯。好吧，你肯定不想去手动创建100亿个红绿灯。然后，突然觉得：“哦，我其实不太喜欢这个红绿灯的外观，所以我得去修改所有这些红绿灯，”那将花去永恒的时间。所以你有了“预制件”这个概念，你可以先设计一个你觉得非常完美、并且尽可能捕捉到所有红绿灯精髓的红绿灯，然后你就可以在各处实例化这个预制件，这样一来，如果以后你的
boss comes to you and says hey i really want the traffic lights to be orange instead of yellow, you could change the prefab and then all of the objects in your world magically get corrected. So that's kind of the premise behind Unity. So you have prefabs, you have game objects, which are instances of prefabs, and then you can assign scripts to either. So you can say, you know know all traffic lights will use this script um and so in a way it's very kind of functional because you don't really there's no guarantees on the order of the scripts and things like that especially if you're creating
老板跑来对你说：“嘿，我真的很希望红绿灯是橙色的，而不是黄色的，”你只需要修改那个预制件，然后你世界里的所有物体就会神奇地全部更新。这就是Unity背后的基本前提。所以你有预制件，有作为预制件实例的游戏对象（game objects），然后你可以把脚本指定给它们中的任意一个。所以你可以说，所有的红绿灯都会使用这个脚本。所以在某种程度上，它是非常功能化的，因为你无法真正保证脚本执行的顺序之类的，特别是如果你在动态创建
objects dynamically and so you know there's some like update function that captures how traffic lights interact with things around them. Time. And move over time. Yeah, change over time. Yeah, yeah. And so that function just kind of runs on the traffic lights. All kind of work independently. so when you move to one of these uh game engines but specifically unity one of the things that jason was talking about before is that you gain cross-platformness to to say that way uh and so
对象的情况下。所以你知道的，会有一个更新函数（update function）来捕获红绿灯如何与其周围的事物进行交互。时间。并且随着时间推移而移动。对，随着时间推移而改变。对，对。所以这个函数就会在红绿灯上运行。它们都是独立运作的。所以当你转向使用这些游戏引擎，尤其是Unity时，正如杰森之前讨论过的那样，你获得的好处之一就是跨平台能力，可以这么说，所以
that is that if you are running on desktop and you decide you want to move to ios because you heard that was the hotness or to android you can you can take your game that's mostly developed and with very little work just run it on the others because you're working at a higher level and so those abstractions handle moving to the other platforms that's right that's right and even you can even write in three different languages um and it all just kind of gets compiled down to the same thing. So Unity has UnityScript, which is kind of like JavaScript, but it doesn't have all the same functions, all the same features of JavaScript, and the syntax is a little different. There's Unity C Sharp, which is exactly C Sharp in terms of syntax,
这就是说，如果你在桌面端运行，然后你决定转移到iOS，因为你听说那是时下最热的，或者转移到Android，你可以把你大部分开发完成的游戏拿过来，只需要做很少的工作就可以在其他平台上运行，因为你在一个更高的抽象层面上工作，所以这些抽象层处理了向其他平台的迁移。没错，正是如此。甚至你还可以用三种不同的语言来编写……然后它都会被编译成相同的东西。所以Unity有UnityScript，它有点像JavaScript，但它没有JavaScript的所有相同函数、所有相同特性，语法也略有不同。还有Unity C Sharp，就语法而言，它完全就是C Sharp，
but not all the libraries from C Sharp are there. It's kind of like a subset of c-sharp and then there's boo which is this language is inspired by python as a syntax that's similar to python but uh um but again it's only for unity um and so it's pretty cool you can you know you can have a team of people and they don't necessarily all have to be writing in the same language although it'd probably be better if everyone was consistent but you can have a you know unity script script for your traffic light that you know calls a unity c sharp script to say is there anyone around me like is there anyone within 100 meters and if there is then the traffic light yells at them or something um so i thought you know it was
但C Sharp中的并非所有库都在那里。它有点像C Sharp的一个子集，然后还有boo，这个语言的语法受到Python的启发，类似于Python，但……但同样它只适用于Unity……所以这非常酷，你知道的，你可以有一个团队，他们不一定都必须用同一种语言编写，尽管如果每个人都保持一致可能会更好，但你可以有一个……你知道的，为你的红绿灯编写的UnityScript脚本，它会调用一个Unity C Sharp脚本来询问，比如“我周围有人吗？比如100米内有人吗？”如果有，那么红绿灯就会对他们大喊大叫什么的……所以我当时想，你知道的，
uh it was pretty cool how like you um can kind of design all these scripts independently and then see sort of i think this is called emergent behavior where it's sort of like the sum is greater than you know or the the whole is greater than the sum of the parts. And so it's like you design this traffic light and it kind of tries to react to anything that comes near it. And then, you know, you design cars, you design people, and eventually you end up with this thing that feels very lifelike and you end up with these kind of very complex behaviors
呃，这真的很酷，比如你可以独立设计所有这些脚本，然后看到某种……我想这被称为涌现行为，也就是某种程度上“整体大于部分之和”。所以就像你设计了这个红绿灯，它会试着对任何靠近它的东西做出反应。然后，你知道的，你设计汽车，你设计人，最后你得到了一个感觉非常栩栩如生的东西，你最终会得到这种非常复杂的行为，
that you could have never really scripted. Another thing about Unity, it's pretty cool. It has all of those things we talked about. It has, you know, the content creation. You can easily take models from Blender, Maya, 3D Studio and import them into Unity. And also a lot of people have written plugins for Unity. Some of them cost money. Some of them are free. But, you know, someone even wrote like a Minecraft kind of plugin. Somebody else wrote a plugin for doing like toon shading. So if you want your game to look like, you know, it's a cartoon. And so, you know, the plugins are really what's going to get you closer to one of these low-level game engines. When you need to do something that Unity can't handle,
这是你以前怎么也写不出来的。关于Unity的另一件事，它非常酷。它具备了我们刚才讨论的所有那些东西。它拥有内容创作功能。你可以轻松地将Blender、Maya、3D Studio的模型导入到Unity中。而且很多人还为Unity编写了插件。其中一些收费，一些免费。但是，你知道的，甚至有人写了一个类似《我的世界》的插件。还有人写了一个用于卡通着色的插件。所以如果你想让你的游戏看起来像是一个卡通片。所以，你知道的，插件才是真正能让你更接近其中一个底层游戏引擎的东西。当你需要做一些Unity无法处理的事情时，
then you can rely on one of these plugins, so you're not just totally lost. All of those plugins and the framework to handle plugins and the cross-compatibility do give you a productivity boost. So instead of spending time creating them all on your own and essentially creating your own version of those things, you are able to offload that to people who have already done it. And that saves you time and gets you down to the cool part
那么你可以依靠这些插件，这样你就不会彻底迷失。所有这些插件、用于处理插件的框架以及跨平台兼容性确实能提升你的生产力。所以，与其花时间自己创造所有这些东西并实质上创建你自己的版本，不如把这些工作卸载给已经做过这些事情的人。这为你节省了时间，并让你能够投入到那些酷炫的部分中去，
about figuring out your awesome AI or your witty story or your amazing animations. But yeah, but that comes at a price. So, you know, all those people... Cost in US dollars. That's right. All those people who made all of those low-level things want to get paid.
比如弄清楚你那厉害的AI、风趣的故事或者惊艳的动画。但是，是的，这是有代价的。所以，你知道，所有那些人……以美元计价。没错。所有那些制作了所有这些底层组件的人都想要得到报酬。
And so you can use the base Unity for free, but it's pretty limiting. I mean, you can't really use plugins. So even if someone else made a plugin that fixes your problem or that adds some functionality to Unity that you need, you can't use it because you only have the basic. To use plugins or to make your own plugins, you have to get Unity Pro, which it's $1,500 base.
所以你可以免费使用基础版的Unity，但它非常受限制。我的意思是，你实际上不能使用插件。所以即使其他人制作了一个可以解决你的问题或者向Unity添加你所需功能的插件，你也无法使用，因为你只有基础版。要使用插件或制作你自己的插件，你必须购买Unity Pro，其基础价格是1500美元。
And then if you want to do Android, it's another $1,500. If you want to do Android, it's another $1,500. If you want to do iOS, it's another $1,500. So to publish a game on Android, iOS, and desktop with Unity Pro, you have to spend $4,500, which is pretty steep. I mean, hopefully you can make that money back in sales, but that's rather tough, I mean. So is it possible with, so you looked more at this than me but the if you have just the unity base could you make a game maybe you couldn't release on ios because of this fee but is it possible to make a game on the desktop that would be actually like people would pay to play um yeah you definitely could do it um i think you might even be able to make
然后如果你想适配Android，又是1500美元。如果你想适配Android，又是1500美元。如果你想适配iOS，又是1500美元。所以在Unity Pro中要在Android、iOS和桌面端发布一款游戏，你必须花费4500美元，这相当昂贵。我的意思是，希望你能通过销售把这笔钱赚回来，但这相当困难，我是说。那么，有没有可能用……所以你对这个的研究比我多，但如果你只有Unity基础版，你能制作一款游戏吗？也许你不能因为这个费用而在iOS上发布，但有可能在桌面上制作一款人们愿意付费游玩的正经游戏吗？嗯，你绝对可以做到……我想你甚至可能做出
a unity so the unity pro for ios costs money but you can use the unity basic on any of the platforms for free so you can even make an android game and charge for it um the only thing is other than you're not getting the plug-ins and a bunch of other features like skeletal animation and some things like that, or like this inverse kinematics. But other than that, you have a Unity splash screen. So when someone launches your app,
一个Unity……所以面向iOS的Unity Pro需要花钱，但你可以在任何平台上免费使用Unity基础版，所以你甚至可以制作一个Android游戏并对其收费，唯一的区别是，除了你得不到插件以及一堆其他功能（如骨骼动画和某些类似的功能，或者像这种反向运动学）。但除此之外，你会看到一个Unity闪屏。所以当有人启动你的应用时，
the first thing they'll see is like powered by Unity for a few seconds, which, you know, that's not too bad. And if my app makes it to the big leagues and sells a million copies, they'll see is like powered by unity for a few seconds which you know that's not too bad and if my app makes it into the big leagues and sells a million copies do i owe some fee per copy to i don't think it's is it per copy i know that uh if you sell more than i think it's like 100 grand or maybe it's even 10 grand then you have to buy pro so part of their license says you can't make more than a certain amount. But I don't think there's any kind of rev share model or anything like that.
他们首先会看到几秒钟的“Powered by Unity”，你知道的，这其实不算太坏。如果我的应用成功进入主流市场并售出了100万份，他们会看到几秒钟的“Powered by Unity”，你知道的，这其实不算太坏，如果我的应用成功进入主流市场并售出了100万份，我是否需要按份数支付版税？我记不清了，是按份数吗？我知道，如果你销售额超过——我想大概是10万美元，或者也许甚至是1万美元，那么你就必须购买Pro版。所以他们的部分许可证条款规定你不能赚取超过特定金额的收入。但我不认为有什么分成模式或类似的东西。
So I think that once you pay for the Pro, and I'm just double checking now. Yeah, once you pay for the Pro, you own it. If you make a billion dollars, it's fine. But you could do it, you could try it out, it if you make a billion dollars it's fine that's nice yeah so you could but you could do it you could try it out and if you make a game you think is awesome you could ship it and
所以我想一旦你支付了Pro版的费用，现在我正在仔细确认。是的，一旦你支付了Pro版费用，它就完全属于你了。如果你赚了10亿美元，也没关系。但你可以这样做，你可以尝试一下，如果你赚了10亿美元，也没关系，这很好，是的，所以你可以，但你可以这样做，你可以尝试一下，如果你制作了一款你认为很棒的游戏，你可以把它发布出去，
then when you get to a hundred thousand and you deal with it i guess that's a good problem to have yeah yeah i mean if you can get away with unity basic then um yeah you can you can always push to put the game out and then retroactively pay them. I'm sure they wouldn't mind. But one thing about Unity is that for what you get, it's actually remarkably cheap. Like the Unreal Engine, I think is like $100,000 or something ridiculous. Unreal Engine pricing. So if you want Unreal engine 4 it is it doesn't even say so i know that uh the github student package did we talk about that last time
然后当你赚到10万美元时再去处理它，我想这是一个幸福的烦恼。是的，是的，我的意思是，如果你能靠Unity基础版过关，那么……是的，你随时可以先把游戏推向市场，然后再追溯支付费用。我确信他们不会介意的。但关于Unity的一点是，考虑到你所获得的价值，它其实相当便宜。比如虚幻引擎，我想大概是10万美元还是什么离谱的数字。虚幻引擎的定价。所以如果你想要虚幻引擎4，它甚至都没写出来，所以我知道……GitHub学生包，我们上次谈过那个吗？
if you're a student and you register with the dot edu address you can go to like github and have like all these free services oh yeah that's right trial things um i thought we talked about it but if we didn't you should check it out i think we talked about it like three or four episodes ago yeah there i think they offer uh i know they offer i think an unreal engine uh license or something you can use for small time stuff uh and getting a taste for it as part of that package oh okay nice so ironically uh unreal 4 they just changed their pricing model recently and now it's 20 per month plus five percent of your revenue ah okay so now it's that's kind of like an interesting dynamic i mean because i mean five percent is really nothing right like even even if you made a hundred thousand dollars in revenue then uh
如果你是一名学生，并且用.edu邮箱注册，你就可以去GitHub获取所有这些免费服务。哦对，没错，那些试用项目……我以为我们讨论过这个，但如果我们没讨论过，你应该去看看。我想我们在三四期节目之前讨论过它。是的，在那里我想他们提供……我记得他们提供了一个虚幻引擎许可证什么的，你可以用于小规模的项目，作为该套餐的一部分来体验一下。哦，好的，太好了！所以具有讽刺意味的是，虚幻4最近刚更改了他们的定价模型，现在是每月20美元加上5%的收入分成。啊，原来如此。所以现在这变成了一种有趣的动态，因为——我的意思是，5%真的不算什么，对吧？比如，哪怕你获得了10万美元的收入，那么
that's just five grand which is the price of unity for all of the uh oh yeah os's yeah so i'm looking at it now. If you are a student, which presumably probably means you have a.edu email address, that's typically how they do that. The GitHub student pack includes a subscription to Unreal Engine 4. Gotcha. So you don't have to pay the $20 a month. I don't know what happens if you make like a billion dollars.
那也才5000美元，这也就是所有那些……哦，对，各操作系统的Unity的价格。所以，我现在正在看。如果你是一名学生，也就是大概意味着你拥有一个.edu电子邮箱地址，他们通常就是这样验证的。GitHub学生包里包含了一个虚幻引擎4的订阅。原来如此。所以你不需要每月支付20美元。我不知道如果你赚了比如10亿美元会发生什么。
I don't know. Wow, that's amazing. Actually, the Unreal Engine, you get the entire source code for the engine, which is something you don't get with Unity, even with the pro version, which is pretty cool. I mean, if you ever wanted to know how like a game engine works, you could just get this subscription for a month and then cancel it and for 20 bucks i mean even if you're not a student then for 20 bucks you get the source code for
我不知道。哇，这太惊人了。实际上，对于虚幻引擎，你可以获得整个引擎的源代码，这是你在Unity中得不到的，哪怕是Pro版本也得不到，这非常酷。我的意思是，如果你曾经想了解游戏引擎是如何工作的，你只需订阅一个月然后取消它，花20美元……我的意思是，即使你不是学生，花20美元你也能得到
ue4 and you can check out how it works it's pretty amazing cool all right well i think that's a wrap thanks Thanks to you all for listening. Yeah, so, you know, short story is Unity is pretty awesome. It takes some getting used to. It's definitely not, it's definitely intended for, you know, game designers. And I learned very quickly that I'm not a game designer. So you had a bunch of stick figures running around the screen. Yeah, it didn't feel natural to me. I kind of wanted, like, I'm like, oh, well oh how am i going to design this like crazy particle engine and i
UE4的源代码，你可以研究它是如何运作的。这真是太棒了。好了，我想就到这里，谢谢。谢谢大家的收听。是的，所以，简单来说，Unity非常棒。它需要一些时间去适应。它绝对不是……它绝对是为游戏设计人员准备的。我很快就意识到我不是一个游戏设计人员。所以你有一堆火柴人在屏幕上跑来跑去。是的，这让我觉得很不自然。我有点想要……我想，哦，好吧，我要怎么设计这个疯狂的粒子引擎，我
realized like this is really meant for like building a gigantic level and having a bunch of like experiences and i was thinking about more in terms of like like i was thinking about like a board game engine that would like play any board game and like kind of like encode the rules in a script and it's just like I was trying to like put a square peg in a round hole but but for people who are like designing a real game and have kind of a background in game design I think this is an amazing tool so cool all right until next time yeah have a good one guys catch you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to
意识到这实际上是用来构建一个巨大的关卡并获得一堆体验的。我考虑的更多的是……比如我当时在想一个棋盘游戏引擎，可以玩任何棋盘游戏，并且把规则写在脚本里，就像是我试图把方钉塞进圆孔里。但对于那些正在设计真正的游戏并且有游戏设计背景的人来说，我认为这是一个了不起的工具。好了，下次见！拜拜，各位，回见。片头曲是Biner Pilot的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及演绎、改编该作品，但你必须向
Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。